He's 55 now,
dog.
Mommy's put your jeans up high and
tight.
Chris.
Christina,
I'm so honored that you did that.
Put it in the instagram post.
Oh,
I can't believe it.
I don't even know what it means.
You don't.
I still don't.
I remember being on your show and I was
like,
what is Mommy's mean?
What does everybody call you guys?
Genes.
It's just stupid.
It really started with like,
what's the dumbest thing we could call a
show your mom's house talking about
genes and mommies and it's dumb on that
forest.
But it's hilarious.
Like your,
your shows a very fun,
silly show you,
you guys obviously have a good time.
We have the best time.
It is like it's how Tom and I normally
are and then we just put microphones.
Which is good.
It's a stupid farts and I don't know.
I love it.
I feel like too,
I feel like we,
uh,
we serve a demographic like,
okay,
for instance,
I was at the rite aid.
I was going to go use the toilet and
this guy stocking the shelves goes
Christina p.
and I was like,
yeah,
how do you know?
And he's like,
I'm a mommy and this is fucking awesome.
Like this is,
these are the people,
the people that are stocking shit and
driving the trucks and like sitting in
cubicles and these days,
the podcasting world of humans,
people that are doing other stuff.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
So not like watching a show,
like if you're watching a show for the
most part,
you're sitting down and watching it,
but if you like listening to a podcast,
you're doing other stuff of cleaning the
house,
doing whatever and you know,
laughing and you guys put up fucking
around those as well.
Like how much of your show is video?
Like what percentage of your audience.
Oh,
that's funny.
Video stuff.
What do you mean?
Who Watches Youtube stuff?
Like what's the difference between like
the Youtube bonds versus the audio?
It's smaller,
but yeah,
the audio is the hardcores and then.
And then interesting videos.
Secondary.
Yeah.
But a lot of people would have thought,
no way,
like videos always going to be seeing it
as better because it's an added element.
Yeah.
But I have a theory,
it's because our show we play like a
porno clips in the towns and stuff
that's not appropriate for the
workplace.
So if you've got youtube on your
earplugs at your state,
your speakers or whatever,
and then it's all fuck me and then fired
from your job.
Her God damn.
I can't believe Tommy met her.
I know.
And I was like texting him like don't
forget your family.
You have a child with me like you would
ever,
you know.
Yeah,
I know.
No,
I can't.
That's the craziest part.
But yeah,
it's been a great show and it's,
you know,
we have you to thank because you were
the one that told us to start it until
everybody started though back in the
day.
But you got to do a podcast to do 100
people.
But luckily 50 of them listened.
Thank God 30 probably.
But some of them are really good.
There's some really good podcasts that
have come out
of my stupid stone suggestions.
Are you kidding me?
You're the great motivator.
The great challenger,
the great beginner of fat shaming
campaigns.
That was great.
I can't take credit for that.
That fat shame was all Bert and tom
talking shit to each other,
but don't put that.
But then you came up with the idea to
have the challenge.
The challenge.
Yes.
The weight loss contest.
Well we sat down,
we tried to figure out what to do,
which we should have like something fun,
like some sort of.
Because there's also an issue that's
going on like it's going on right now
with Ari and it was going on with them
where people on the outside think it's
serious and this is probably a good time
to address this.
Like people on the outside of things
that were actually mad at Ari.
Ari is actually like not good for his
word.
That's.
This is a,
these are jokes folks were fucking
around.
You know,
I mean this is all just and so all you
people that take it seriously don't take
anything unless we say this is serious.
Don't take it seriously.
Like all that bird is fat thomas fats
up.
They were,
we were having a great time with it.
They were having fun with it and the Ra,
a welter stuff.
That stuff is bullshit.
All right.
Red is like for real.
One of the most honest guys I've ever
met in my life and for sure he wasn't
excited about paying for those guys to
go to fucking Europe for a soccer game.
That doesn't mean he wouldn't have
honored this bet,
but then it got complicated because I
paid for the bat and I sent those guys
to a basketball game.
What was the game again?
Cavs warriors.
Is that a big game?
It was,
yeah,
for sure.
At the time.
I don't understand.
Do you get it?
Do I get it?
Go to a basketball game.
The most boring thing in the world for
me,
watched some guys throw a ball.
Players in the world are in those two
teams.
Did they do really good at throwing the
ball in the hole?
Really,
really good at it.
He didn't do you like sports at all?
Really?
But I thought for sure not football.
No.
I get so bored.
Bored the shit out of me too,
and Tom's been trying to explain this
shit to me for years and I'm like,
I don't.
Okay.
They run five seconds and then the start
and then and then comes the show after
the show or the four white guys talk
about the fucking game.
They just watched for two more hours
making the stupid jokes that fucking
white guys that do the fucking
commentary in there.
The worst.
You can't find funnier.
People that skip bayless kids,
that's his name,
but could you imagine being stuck on a
plane with that guy right now?
He just keeps talking to you with shit
breath.
Oh God,
yeah.
I'll do a bad guy.
I shouldn't talk shit.
Terrible,
terrible person.
I'm sure.
And they're all,
you know,
dogs.
They're all bad looking dudes.
You know what I like?
Terrible boring things though.
I like.
I watch,
I've watched professional pool hunting
shows like my wife comes home and she
looks at our dvr.
She's like,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
This is the dvr.
Kickboxing,
MMA,
a bow hunting,
bow hunting,
bow hunting.
You know,
like a real crime stories like what the
fuck is wrong with you?
Like murder,
killing,
punching,
murder.
So it's like most of it though is
hunting.
I'm so obsessed with hunting.
Most of my dvr is like these bowhunting
show that's your jam.
So that's your hobby.
And Are you watching it for tips and
figure out what to do in certain
situations,
which seems ridiculous.
Like would just shoot the animal.
What the fuck?
Get near it.
Shoot it.
It's,
it's one of those things on the outside
it looks like very simple,
but on the inside it's very complex.
That's how everything.
Okay.
Like surfing,
that's super easy.
No,
it was like the hardest fucking thing in
the world to learn to do.
Have you ever seen an indoor one?
No,
dude,
they have these indoor ones.
They have a woman,
Austin Bro.
You get on a surfboard and you,
you can go on it for like 10 minutes.
Like they say.
It's an amazing way to get good because
you don't have to wait for waves.
It's a machine.
So there's this huge pool.
You get in there with a surfboard and
you surf like fucking crazy and you just
keep doing it and you don't have to
paddle.
Paddle,
paddle out turned the fucking board
around.
Well,
it's also your whole.
I would imagine you're developing those
stabilizer muscles,
right?
Like I was talking to guys that have
looked at that like,
look,
you just surf around and you get used to
like balancing.
So this would be a good way.
I don't like that guy.
Just kidding.
Just kidding buddy.
Fuck that guy.
Like his face is.
It'd be a good way to develop all those
weird.
Like that's one of the things that you
realize when you start doing yoga is
that there's all these weird muscles
that you didn't know that were weak,
like these weird stabilizer muscles in
your feet.
Like the number one thing that bothered
me when I first started doing yoga is my
feet.
My feet would give out before anything.
I was like,
this is so weird.
They would just give out your ankles.
You mean?
Oh my feet like the heel because you're
standing on one foot and you're
balancing so your foot has to kind of
like do all this,
like,
you know,
like adjusting and while that's
happening they're like,
my foot's getting fatigued,
like the arch of my foot starts hurting
and I have to put it down.
Damn.
Yeah.
That's like,
it took me a long time to get past that.
Well,
so now were you a huge fan of hot yoga
before you came up with this challenge?
Yeah,
I've been doing it for a few years now.
Doing it.
It's pretty seriously for two years.
I did it on and off for a couple of
years before that,
but I got real serious about two years
and two months ago.
I just started doing it every week.
Now.
What's the benefit of the heat?
Cold heat shock proteins.
There's a,
and this hasn't been proven,
but there's the study they're doing
right now I think at Harvard about this
because it's been proven that sauna,
there's a woman that I have on the
podcast all the time.
She's brilliant.
Her name is Dr Rhonda Patrick and she's
like one of my favorite people and her,
um,
she's done a bunch of work on Saunas.
She's kind of obsessed with cryotherapy,
cold shock proteins and heat shock
proteins and your body has a response to
extreme heat,
extreme cold by producing these anti
inflammatory.
And when you go into a hot sauna,
I think it's four times a week if you
could do it four times a week,
it reduces mortality amongst all causes
by 40 percent,
no shed,
stroke,
heart attack,
cancer,
everything.
And it's because most of the issues that
people have health wise stem from
inflammation and inflammation from
sugar,
poor diet,
but it's all,
you can mitigate a lot of that
inflammation with sauna.
And I think yoga mimics the sauna
because it is so fucking hot in the
room,
right?
The room is 105 degrees and then once
you start exercising,
your body is through the roof.
I mean I am like,
a lot of times they're doing poses and I
have my arm straight out and I'm
watching water just poor out of my body
under the ground.
I don't have a shirt on,
right,
so it's not like it's coming out of a
wet shirt.
It's just pouring off my body trip,
trip,
just squeezing all the water out of my
body and I drink a large 64 ounce bottle
of water with ice during the entire
class.
So in that 90 minute class,
I'm 64 ounces of water.
Yeah.
So there's a tremendous amount of stress
on your body from that heat and from the
poses themselves.
And so,
uh,
I would like to see what happens when
the results of this study come back
because I think they're going to show
probably a similar effect to like the
anti inflammatory markers in the blood
that you see from sauna.
That's.
I did not know.
That song is amazing.
If you can get a sauna like near your
house.
Why now?
We're just talking about this morning,
man.
They them that you can install a small
one.
Like the new studio has a sauna.
Do it.
You can come on over.
I'll tell you why.
That's so crazy.
Yeah,
I'm on that.
A primal diet had been done subsistence
diet.
Yeah.
For like,
I don't know,
almost a year now.
That's the big thing.
She says,
my trainer,
I'd take,
she said it's the inflammation,
it's the inflammation,
you know?
Yup,
Yup.
No,
I see.
I got it from a woman once.
She told me she's a trainer and she
said,
and she was talking to me about back
issues and issues that people have and
she was one of the,
this is going to sound really weird,
but one of the best ways that we figured
out how to help people with back issues
is a,
get them to go on a gluten free diet.
And I was like,
what's this?
This was a few years back.
I was having some neck problems and she
was almost like a gluten free diet.
Why?
And she's like,
well,
gluten causes inflammation.
A lot of people.
I was like,
oh,
that sounds like some new age hippie
bullshit.
Right.
So then I started looking into it and
then I realized like,
oh,
there's something to this.
And then I'm like,
oh,
it's not just gluten,
it's actually refined carbohydrates and
refined sugars and all that stuff.
But gluten to,
you know,
um,
maynard from tool,
you know,
that dude and Keenan tool is,
he's awesome.
It's a really good dude.
But he also has his own vineyard and an
a in a restaurant in Austria.
You ever doing an Australia is a,
I didn't know until he told me it's a
small restaurant that serves like small
plates.
It's like sorta like
Tapa.
So that's like a similar career path,
I don't know.
But anyway,
he has um,
they serve pasta that is heirloom pasta
and I'm like,
well,
what do you mean?
He's like,
we'll use heirloom wheat because the
wheat that they used to sell,
like W,
we,
that people used to grow like way back
in the early days was much more low
yield,
I'd say the same thing that people have
done to tomatoes and a lot of things by
making them more robust.
When they did this to wheat,
they,
they made a much higher yield wheat.
So if you have an acre of wheat,
you get much more wheat out of it.
But it has much more complex gluten's in
it.
And it's more difficult for your body to
process.
So one of the things that I noticed when
we went to Italy is I was eating pasta
over there and it didn't get me this
horrible brick in my stomach feeling
like you want to die is this,
why is it different?
And he was explaining,
he was like,
your body is struggling to process this
modern gluten,
this modern wheat,
but he sells this stuff that's heirloom.
Just sorta like those ugly tomatoes,
those delicious heirloom tomatoes.
Yes.
Same thing.
That's what a tomato used to be like.
They used to be this like weird,
funky looking but super delicious.
Almost like a fruit.
I don't even eat pasta.
I haven't had it in like a year.
Like,
you know,
every now and then I have a nibble,
but the thought of eating a bowl of it,
now it's repulsive.
Empty.
There's no nutrition,
right?
There's nothing in it.
It's just dog shit.
And it's going to turn to slop on your
body,
you know?
And I don't like it.
Yeah.
I used to love it.
I eat it every now and then I'll still
eat it.
I hate,
the other day I made sausage and put a
pasta like I bought some of that Italian
pasta.
Yeah,
the real deal.
The real deal.
You get it.
I think it's called double zero wheat.
They have.
Yeah.
That's what it is.
And you can get it from Italy,
like get it on Amazon.com.
Nice.
Yeah.
Because,
uh,
I order eggs that are like super organic
fancy ones to the eggs.
Do you have chickens?
Fresh eggs.
Do you guys have a nice yard?
Did you get into a little chicken coop?
See,
Jamie was good.
No.
Yeah,
I uh,
I want to get chickens.
Yeah,
because I like,
you know,
in Europe the yolks are nice and bright
orange.
It shouldn't be yellow.
No really nasty.
No,
that's why you see vegetarian fed
chickens,
like they don't want that.
Chickens want bugs and worms and beetles
and mice.
They're little monsters.
They nasty,
nasty,
nasty shit.
But it's such a good deal.
Like you give them food,
you let him roam around your yard,
they pluck at the grass and they eat
bugs and you know,
and they give you eggs.
It's like a super sweet deal.
Now,
do they?
Shit everywhere.
Everywhere your dog.
You have a dog,
right?
I got two dogs.
Okay.
Your dog's going to eat all the chicken.
Shit.
It's fucking gross.
Marshall goes in the in the yard and
just go with chicken shit like Easter
egg hunt.
So gross circle of life,
right?
Just gobbling up chicken turds.
You're like,
dude,
you're so nasty.
Nasty dog.
And then he wants to run over and kiss
you.
Yeah,
of course.
And then does he sleep in your bed too?
Fucking way?
No,
no,
no.
The doggie doggy sleep.
Sleeps in his dog bed.
In your room.
No,
no,
no.
Somewhere else in the house?
No,
he sleeps in my office.
Oh,
okay.
Dog Bed.
He's got a sweet little setup.
This is the puppy you just got.
Yeah,
he's 11 months now.
He's a big boy now.
He's full grown golden retrievers.
They,
they get to be like full grown pretty
quick.
He's the sweetest dog.
They're such great dogs.
They're so loving and they're such smart
family dogs.
Yeah.
And it's really smart.
You know,
like he,
he just,
he gets it,
you know,
like you can talk to me,
come here buddy.
Like he just comes,
he gets it.
He's like no communication with them.
It's very simple,
you know,
and he's always happy,
just a big sweetie.
Yeah.
They have a good demeanor.
Those tax.
Yeah.
Really peaceful.
Can he chill alone or does he need to be
with the person?
No,
he chills alone.
I can just go,
hey bro wants you to scope out in the
backyard.
And he goes out in the yard swimming by
himself,
which is kind of hilarious.
Like the pools there and he just dives
in the water by himself and then as
he's,
what's,
what's really silly is as he's swimming,
he's paddling and he creates these
splashes and he tries to bite them.
So it's splashed.
It's like,
it's so silly.
So silly.
I love doggies.
Another great.
I want to hold,
I want to like 10 of them.
I have these little shit dogs,
these,
they're called Brussels Griffon.
That's my breed.
They look like pugs but with more for
and they're just so stupid and I love
them,
but they always want to be next to you.
They always want to snuggle course.
You're nice.
I am.
Yeah.
They want to be near Nice,
wouldn't it?
I'm very snuggly.
I know.
I liked that shit.
What do you do?
I don't know.
People that don't like dogs,
like what don't you like about them?
They're sweet,
but they're loving and they're stoked to
see you all the time.
There was a weird thing though with
people that only like dogs and don't
like people,
so that's too much,
you know,
it's like your personality probably
sucks,
man.
The person that's strictly dog.
Is that what you mean?
And I thought,
yeah,
that's fucked up therapy problem.
You know,
the next step is people judge people.
There's horse people in my neighborhood
or judge them.
Uh,
I don't,
I don't like horses.
Fuck them.
I don't want to ride them.
I don't like them.
And they smell bad.
I mean they're pretty firm until the
Whitney.
No,
I know.
I see her on instagram.
She does.
She loves her horse.
What is,
what do they love so much about these
horses when these crazy?
Yeah,
she's very smart.
Like one of the smartest people I've
ever met,
but she's fucking insane in a good way.
But,
but like she has so much information.
Every time I talked to her have to
google something.
Like what?
What does she know about telling me to
tell me?
Dammit.
Weird.
She,
she told me about weird violent sports I
didn't even know existed.
I'm.
One of the things she was telling me is
why people have a fear of public
speaking.
This was something that she said the
last time she was on the podcast and I
said why?
She's like,
because in the past when you spoke in
public,
it was because you were trying to make a
case for your survival.
Oh Wow.
That's interesting.
They were looking at you like you fucked
up and there was a big group of people
judging you.
I was like,
oh,
interesting.
I would think it's fear of alienation
from the pack.
At the same reason people are afraid of
success.
It's because you don't want to lose your
connection to the tribe because it
separates you from the tribe.
Well,
as a comic,
don't you notice that when people get to
be a certain level of success,
there's some of them,
like some of them,
some of them just stay cool and they
just hang no matter what.
Like Ron White,
Ron Wyden has always just hanging out
and he's about as big as you get.
I mean Ron Wyden is sold out fucking
arenas.
Right?
But you know,
you hang with Ronnie,
he's like,
hey man,
what's going on?
You know,
drank gives you a hug and he's the best.
Right.
But like some people they get insulated
and they get weird and then they lose
touch with everybody and then their
comedy suffers.
Yeah.
Well because you can't be removed from
the world to talk about the world.
That doesn't really work that way,
does it?
No,
but I think people,
well I don't know.
Like how do you stay normal?
You're super successful.
I think one of the reasons,
because I do a lot of other shit,
like the yoga.
Yeah.
I think doing yoga,
like difficult,
doing Jujitsu,
bowhunting bond,
he's one of the hardest things I've ever
done.
It's fucking hard.
It's super difficult.
Super difficult to get accurate,
super intense pressure on the line when
you have to execute a shot and a living
creature and then you know,
just to get obsessed with the whole
methodology behind it and all the
technique and all the learning and
studying it and just.
I get obsessed with things,
so like doing things I suck at,
like yoga,
bowhunting and Jujitsu.
You get more humble,
you know,
I slept less a Jujitsu that I do with
other things,
but I still suck in comparison to people
that are really good.
That's really interesting.
I like that because I started baking
very domestic a and I suck at it.
Fucking terrible ad you have to think,
but I have to think and I'm learning and
I.
and it's for the thrill and the joy of
doing it.
It's not,
it's not result oriented.
And I think that's the difference
between hobbies and career,
right?
There's no who gives a shit.
There's no results that need to happen
with you and bow hunting.
If they happen,
great,
if not,
whatever,
but it's for the enjoyment of the
activity versus like results,
you know like,
well,
why should I play the piano?
I'm not going to get to Carnegie Hall
with it says you have to get to Carnegie
Hall.
Just enjoy the activity or hobby well in
Indiana and being obsessed with the
process of learning because you're a
beginner.
Whereas opposed to like if you're some
mega celebrity superstar comedian that
sells out giant arenas,
you're not.
You're not a beginner man.
I mean you're.
And if that's all you do,
if all you do is something you're
awesome at and everybody loves you and
you go out,
what's up everybody?
Or you know,
like
there's a weird disconnect that happens
with people and you see it with certain
comics.
I mean you see a clear progression in
their stardom and their act falling
apart and that is because of the loss of
touch with reality and what's normal in
the world.
And also you get to fucking comfortable
ride complacency and you start believing
that you're awesome self critical aspect
of analyzing your act,
going over with a fine tooth comb.
Like when you just did this special,
right?
I'm sure you must have spent a lot of
time combing every,
every,
every word mattered,
every sentence mattered,
every joke manner.
That's why you're really good.
And that's,
that's the whole thing.
Like you have to fucking hate yourself
so much.
I'm so glad you said that because.
Because I,
I,
you know,
like I said,
I,
I've told you before we really,
October ninth,
I was just some Douche bag who sold 200
tickets in Portland and I'm still that
person.
But I'm saying like,
uh,
October 10th,
100,
8 million people now have access to my
staff.
It's a bit of a mind fuck.
But the good news is I'm still
self-loathing enough to be like,
you gotta grind like you still,
I'm still gonna.
Go to the comedy store.
Sure work out this next hour.
And it's always the work of it.
But you do have to fucking hate.
You can't believe the hype that you're
great.
No,
you know,
you know all the various incarnations
your act has gone through in each bit
has gone through.
When someone comes to see you,
they're like,
we're going to go secret with Mommy's.
See you.
And it's the first time hearing all the
material and they love and like,
oh my God,
it was fucking amazing.
You know better because you know,
you've gone through it all and you
picked it apart and you know,
I always tell people like I'm done.
I'm not like the biggest fan of me.
Like I don't do better no matter how
much I murder of your comedy and you're
like one of the most thoughtful thought
provoking,
funny,
articulate,
like out.
You know what I mean?
You're here really deep and good.
I've know myself too well,
Alec,
I don't believe.
Yeah,
you can't.
You can't.
That's what I'm talking to tom about
this so far this morning too.
Or we're walking and I was like that.
I think that's how you,
you keep your career is if you struggle
is though it was the first.
You know what I mean?
Like you,
you don't think you're all that,
do stuff that you're sucking that to do
the baking,
do the hot yoga,
do pilates,
pauses.
Very underrated.
Fucking it kicks my ass.
I hate it.
I like to exercise,
but after I had my kid I was like,
I don't want to be brittle and hunched
over and in Shitty at 50 like I'm
looking to 50 and plot is like a core
thing.
Gosh,
your whole core and that's the thing
that people don't think about.
It's like a hip word.
Use like core.
What does that,
what does that.
I didn't know what that was.
What it really means,
which you really got to work,
is not just your muscles,
like your thighs or your arms work,
the
stuff that keeps you upright.
All those muscles that stabilize your
back,
all those muscles that allow you to have
good posture.
All those muscles that keep your discs
from compressing.
Yeah,
like all.
And that's one of the things that yoga
does.
It stretches you out and
get back into yoga.
I go,
Tommy.
Yeah.
I'm going to go.
Because when I had a kid at a fucked up,
I got Sciatica because he know your,
your body literally splits in half.
Your pelvis is to two bones,
right?
That come apart and baby comes out and
then it has to heal.
So I'm two years postpartum and,
and it's just now kind of coming back.
But yeah dude,
it's been like,
it's,
it's brutal.
I'm sure being 39 or 41 I had a baby
probably wasn't helpful,
but that plays,
it kicks my and I'm bad at it too.
I suck at polities and I make fun of
myself the whole time.
I'm like,
I don't have perfect form for the best
at this you've ever seen,
but I do still do it.
You still fucking push yourself while
doing things that you suck at I think is
his giant
for anyone doing anything.
Because I think that if you get,
you get to certain levels of proficiency
at things,
you can get lost in that thing.
And I think one of the best ways
especially maybe I don't.
Maybe I'm just looking at in terms of
creative endeavors,
because like standup obviously is so
dependent upon your ideas,
so dependent upon creativity that one of
the best ways for me to have other
thoughts other than like just my
immediate act and doing shows and
travel,
you know,
like that's the worst thing that happens
to comics,
right.
They started doing an airplane jokes
because they're on airplanes all the
time and hotel jokes and they just lose
their perspective.
Right.
Do other shit like live a life.
Yeah.
Live a life and do stuff that's fucking
hard.
No.
Have some struggles so that the standup
struggle,
it doesn't seem that standup is the
easiest fucking part of my day.
All
right.
After,
you know,
doing it for 14 years.
Yes.
Yoga and running and all this different
shit I do.
The standup part is the easiest part.
You know,
it's so interesting too.
I was thinking about,
uh,
you know,
I've been,
I've been doing it for 14 years before I
got this first special and I was like
thinking about uh,
the crazy shit you go through to,
to be a comic and like the horrible
positions.
I put myself as a woman too.
It's especially fucked up because you're
like if feature act and you're staying
in motels where the door faces the
fucking parking lot and you're doing
some Hibachi grill and some weirdos
going to try to pay you with a fur coat
instead of money this week.
You do like who?
Like what kind of sickness was I in in
my twenties and thirties were I thought
that was okay.
You know,
you really would only do it when you're
young.
You want to start that right now.
It would be such a grind.
Like guys like Dean del Ray,
like give it up to that guy.
That guy didn't even start doing stand
up to you is like,
I think it was like 46 or some crazy
shit like that.
Deans in his fifties.
Yes.
He looks great.
Looks Great.
He looked like shit just a few years
ago.
He,
uh,
he got off sugar completely.
Oh,
that's right.
He was eating candy all day,
had like a real sugar problem,
and he went to the doctor and the doctor
said,
hey bro,
you're going to get fucking diabetes.
You are right now prediabetic.
He's like,
see this?
Look at your blood.
You see the show them the blood markers
while you're on the way like you are
right now.
Officially prediabetic.
What do you do?
And these are,
well,
he gummy bears and Shit and gummy bears,
man.
He would eat candy all day long.
It's crazy.
It's so bad for you.
Sugar is the worst for you.
That's the fucking devil is the devil.
But they say your body doesn't really
differentiate between fruit and candy.
I,
I had to.
I had a trainer that called it nature's
candy.
Fruit Nature's candy crunch.
Guy Goes,
he used to live with cowboy boots on.
Don't beat.
And that name was candy.
Have yourself a wheat biscuit.
He went,
he was a minor.
Yeah.
He was telling me about nature's candy,
the evil of it.
And I was like,
that's true.
It's just fucking sugar.
Yeah.
But so good.
Let's go the other day.
Oh,
so delicious and nice.
Ripe Mango.
They do.
That makes me shit.
That's like lightening.
You know what makes me shit my fucking
coffee.
Caveman coffee stuff opens up sometimes.
Sometimes I shit like the other day I
shit and I tell them my seven year old
about it.
Tell her she's like,
Daddy,
you almost done it.
Goes playing with her.
And I had to take this horrible shit
just taking her to a martial arts class
and we got home and I go,
I'll play with you.
But first I got to go potty.
And I was in that five minutes.
She's like,
Daddy,
you almost done.
I'm like,
look,
this shit I took was so huge.
I was almost going to show it to you.
As I say the poop.
I don't say shit.
Don't know why I'm preparing a curse in
front of it.
I do occasionally,
but here's,
here's the problem.
When when she was three,
when my youngest was three,
we were skiing.
She's been skiing since you like to.
And we took her skin and uh,
we're putting all our stuff back in and
we had everything stacked up,
but we're putting the bags away,
we're getting ready to leave.
And my wife goes,
you honey,
you didn't put your,
your helmet back in,
in the bag.
She looks to helmet,
she likes the bag.
She goes,
shit fucked three girls three looking at
her bag.
Oh my gosh.
It's great.
And my wife,
just girls,
we were trying not to laugh to encourage
her,
but it was fucking hilarious because it
was a natural.
Like,
she's like,
that's where you're supposed to say,
daddy says shit.
Well that's the problem is that our son
has two comics for parents throwing a
tantrum.
And then he pushed his time and he hits
him and were just like,
hey buddy.
Now to almost two slash 22 months and
we're starting that potty training
stuff.
So we got to come up with a word,
like you say,
poor or so were we started using dump
because we want to be like,
oh,
that'd be really funny.
When he's in school and he's like,
I have to take a dump.
It's not dirty,
it's just funny.
So we started with dump,
but he can't say it,
so it's turned to poo poo poo poo poo
poo trip.
And I want to give you a kid,
a word for shit that they can't say no.
That's right.
So it's got to be fun stuff,
Mama Dada.
Very simple.
Now did your.
My son insists on sitting on my lap
while I take a shit.
Sometimes the difference between the way
kids treat the girl,
the Mommy and Daddy,
mommy,
they cling to me.
Did you breastfeed or did you pump or
did?
Yeah,
I did.
For both.
Pump thing to both.
Man did it all.
Formula breast.
So just connected to you.
Just like physically,
you are the source of nutrients.
You're the source of love.
You're the source of life.
There's so much going on.
So crazy.
What does it feel?
Powerful?
Yeah,
it's the best.
It really as far as being a woman in
society,
like Societaly,
it's not that great,
but I will say that like reproduction
stuff.
It's fucking awesome.
How is it not great?
Societaly?
I mean,
you know,
we're still second class citizens.
Let's be honest,
women are,
you know,
your power is,
there's not,
I don't really feel,
uh,
it's not really,
you know,
blah,
blah blah.
It's not really,
but you don't exist in a corporate
world.
So.
But where do you find the deficit in
standup?
Definitely.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think it's starting to come around,
but if you'll look at like where we're
at now,
it feels a little regressive in terms of
where we were in the nineties with
female cow I would say.
Yeah.
What do you think the source of that is?
Uh,
that's.
I,
I cannot.
I don't know.
I think nine slash 11 changed us,
made us more conservative in some ways.
A little more insulated.
I don't know.
I think it's just a lack of quality.
I think when someone like you comes
along for real.
I've told you this before.
I mean I saw you at the comedy store
like four or five years ago when I ran
up to like one set that you had.
I'm like,
Oh dude,
you're one of the funniest people alive.
I can't take off.
Thank you.
You're very encouraging of me and I
always am so thankful.
You're the reason I got a special.
I was in here at years ago and you're
like,
you should have an hour.
And I was like,
Ooh,
maybe I should get a manager and an
agent.
Like I wasn't even thinking in terms of
paying like intelligent.
What were you thinking?
I was fucking just like,
I just want to be good at the.
I just want to be good,
but that's the right attitude.
Yeah.
Agronomically.
The people that are like,
I need a special now those people suck.
Right?
Like the people that are trying to do
something that's way out of their reach.
Like the people that are like,
you know,
I need to be filling arenas.
Like,
no,
you need to fucking good 10 minutes.
A piece of shit.
Like really talking about like those are
the crazy people,
right?
The people that are like really good at
promotion but really bad at standup.
But then however,
there's people who are really talented
but don't have enough business savvy.
So I think there needs to be some kind
of like thing where you start to learn
the business and you become responsible
for that end of it.
And I think I was not taking
responsibility.
Well I think the thing about standup is
that there is a very,
especially today and there's a
difference between today and 10 years
ago or 20 years ago because there's more
opportunity and because there's more
opportunity because of there's youtube
and there's social media,
there's people that have become very
famous just through twitter and
instagram and social media.
So all this new opportunity has opened
up more possibilities so people are less
stingy and there's more of a sense of
community for whatever reason.
Particularly in La.
La has a very good sense of community.
So even if you're not like the most
business savvy,
you can be around a lot of people like
myself or like other people that are
encouraging and then help and tell
everybody about their friends.
And like it's one of the cool things
about comedy.
Like you'll go to like Tom's page if
someone else is doing something and it'd
be like,
Hey,
check out,
you know,
full trod.
He's fucking hilarious,
you know.
Check out Ian Edwards.
By the way.
Ian Edwards is punk.
He's at the laughing skull in Atlanta
this weekend.
One of the best I've been trying to fit.
He's too fucking laid back.
He's,
he's,
Oh yeah.
I mean when he talks,
you're like,
what you like,
come on,
pick it up.
Come on.
He's like the opposite of me.
He's Vegan.
He falls asleep constantly.
That motherfucker will sit down and in
five minutes he's out cold.
Oh No.
I took pictures of him on a plane the
other day because we were flying to
Vegas.
It's a 40 minute flight.
He's out cold protein dude.
It's a lack of vitamins for sure because
he doesn't eat well.
It's not his.
He does eat vegan.
Look at um,
alcohol.
Um,
but he,
he definitely doesn't.
He doesn't take any supplements.
He doesn't like make sure that he has a
complete balanced amino acid profile to
is foods.
And like I was telling to you that
either though,
but that's a lot of work.
It is of work,
but that's what to do if you want to be
fucking jacked.
He said he would eat elk.
Good.
He said he would eat it because I killed
it,
you know,
and he knows where it came from and it's
not factory farmed and he doesn't have
to participate in the whole factory farm
system.
So I'm going to cook them some meat
trial.
I'm going to turn him or we get old.
Are you going to put it on instagram?
I would love to see it.
Yeah.
I am a film.
That shit.
I'm going to have Jamie set up a camera
and a tripod.
The new studio has a grill of course.
Has a course that as it grows,
big iron yoder pellet grills.
It's fucking amazing.
You say you're moving
on my next week,
next week.
Doot Doo doot doot,
doot,
doot.
Enormous.
It's daddy's playhouse.
It's going to be a good time.
I can't wait.
I'm very excited.
Super Cool.
But uh,
so we're going to turn it in when it
gets over there.
Okay,
yeah,
yeah.
What?
Why is he he?
Is it,
is it a,
is it a moral thing?
Is it moral thing?
It's a health thing.
It's a bunch of.
He was eating very poorly.
He was eating junk food and just
bullshit food,
pizza and burgers and stuff.
He felt like shit and made a decision
for his health and then along the way
started examining the moral consequences
of factory farming and he.
He's just a really smart guy,
smart guy.
Super Smart and just again Atlanta
laughing's call this weekend.
He's one of the funniest guys alive.
I just worked with them.
Sell Mellow too.
Melos.
I've known Ian for I want to say like 25
years.
Yeah,
we've been friends.
We've been friends since I'm shit.
The early nineties.
What?
Where,
when,
how has he been here that long?
He has been what Ian did.
His Ian is a really good writer and one
of the things that happened along the
way,
he started getting a lot of jobs,
writing,
writing on television shows and that
happens to guys or they do that.
It happened to Fitzsimmons who's also
one of the best comics alive and they
get distracted by other people's work
and then people don't realize how good
they are at stand up.
If you get a chance to see Greg
Fitzsimmons,
he is one of the fucking best comments
alive and greg and I started out
literally a week apart from each other.
Same Club in Boston.
He's great.
He's best.
He's a great human being tail and he's
super funny.
He's super funny and super smart and
just a sweetheart.
He just.
And just ridiculous.
He's so funny.
That's true about writing for other
people and because I,
I wrote for cartoons for many years and
I do feel like it sucks your,
your,
your juice out of your voice.
And then I worked on Chelsea for a
minute and wrote on that show and I was
like,
I can't,
I can't.
Do you feel like you're cheating,
you know,
your own voice and your own ship working
so much on other people's stuff and then
not at all at your own stuff.
And then all of a sudden you're thing is
done and you're behind instead of like
at the same spot you were when you
started.
You're behind because you don't even
know your act anymore.
You got to go over your material.
You're not really working anymore.
It's not in your conscious.
It's not always there.
Was it Louis Ck?
I was talking about when he was a writer
on some late was at the tonight show or
something.
I want to say he was a writer on one of
the big late night shows and he was,
he got it pretty young too and he was
like,
this is the best job I could ever hope
for.
And I think I'm going to hate myself if
I stay here because you know that I know
I want to be a comic.
I know somewhere that there's something
out there I need to be doing.
So it's like this gilded cage of,
of being a writer.
Yeah.
Well it's also being on a sitcom.
Do that.
Being on a Sitcom did that to me for
sure.
Oh yeah.
Like you weren't doing your full
potential was working all day.
And then,
um,
I was still doing sets at night,
but I wasn't writing any new material at
all.
I was just doing the same set over and
over again.
And I started this.
I started having some hard sets and one
night the writers came to see me and I
went up late at the comedy store and ate
a,
a platter of Dick's,
just a full,
like a flake,
someone getting married or they bring
over there with the hors d'oeuvres,
eat every trade.
And I just realized like I've become a
bad comic.
Like I used to be good when I was young
and then I got this show and then over
the course of the four years,
five years that I was on the show,
I just might act deteriorated.
And I realized like I got to get back on
the horse and that because of that one
bombing set,
I'm like a year and a half later,
something like that.
Uh,
I got my first album that I did on
warner brothers.
I allow,
that was like 10 years into comedy.
So the whole thing was like a velvet
cage,
you know,
like it's like,
oh,
this is it.
I've made,
everything's going to be beautiful now,
but it's not because you're not doing
your thing.
And it's funny.
Someone asked me like,
well what do you want to do Christina?
What do you want to do?
And I was like,
I'm kind of fucking deal in it.
Like the podcasting world is amazing.
Standups.
Great.
Like I'm,
I'm doing what could you imagine the
show that gives you that kind of freedom
that your podcast get has never.
Do you have any fucking dumb meetings
we'd have to have with the higher aps
about you go,
you can't see genes.
You can talk about mummies kit.
Look,
we've got a survey and people don't
understand what genes is.
You call answer the jeans.
Like I don't mind if you do it once,
just don't just don't do it.
Every show and the moose soup lady.
What's that about that thing.
And I don't want to fuck it.
I don't like answering to people for
stuff.
I didn't like the notes that she had
some Douchey unfunny producer that was
telling you guys how to do your show and
that's what.
That's what it can be all the time.
How many times you can say one thing or
it has the worst.
When you were an actor,
when you act on that show,
would you get lines that you were just
like,
I can't.
How do I know?
No,
not on news radio.
[inaudible] news radio was so good and
the writers were so good and the guy who
ran it,
Paul Simms,
the,
the executive producer,
the creator of the show,
he was a genius and one of the things
that was brilliant about him,
he was,
he still alive,
still a genius.
One of the things is brilliant about him
and he let everybody add the leg.
Dave Foley was like,
almost like the secret producer of that
show was amazing.
But because he was on news radio,
um,
right after kids in the hall,
like you did kids in the hall where he's
one of the primary writers,
he's a really good writer.
So he would,
he would see like,
you know,
the thing is if you ever been on a
sitcom before we ever worked on a
Sitcom,
no.
One of the things you do,
you do a run through.
So you do a table read.
When you go down,
everybody sits down,
go over the lines,
you find out what's funny,
everybody laughs,
uh,
the writers will go back to the writing
room,
they tweak stuff a little bit and then
you go to the floor and you run it.
And so will you do in a run through as
you'll start off.
Okay,
we're seeing the hair and the break
room,
blah blah blah.
And you know,
maybe it just doesn't work.
Maybe it seems like it work,
but it doesn't work.
And Dave would be the guy that goes,
I'm andy,
why don't,
why don't we try this?
Like Vicky,
why don't you walk in here and Andy,
you walk in at the same time and you
guys both say the same thing at the same
time.
And then,
you know,
he'll like come up with like a whole new
scenario to get this point across to
move us into the next scene.
And he would do that in front of the
producers and they would go,
love it.
Perfect,
let's,
let's go with that.
And so they would rewrite the scene and
put Dave's lines and,
and I swear to God,
that might've happened 40 percent of the
time.
Wow.
So if you see that show,
like maybe 40 percent of the scenes at
least were tweaked by Dave Foley.
That's bananas.
And did he get the punch up?
Credit Punch up credit.
But that was the thing is like everybody
was just working to do.
But oddly enough,
Phil Hartman did zero of that.
Phil Hartman was just like,
stick to the script and kill it.
But his character was such a beautiful
character to write for this,
uh,
sort of have tos ridiculous guy who was
just like,
just completely,
you know,
just didn't get it and was like full of
himself.
And he was so good at playing that
character that they would just nail his
character.
I then he would just go out and smash
it.
That's crazy.
That was a little too young when that
show came out.
I didn't get to see it.
But Phil Hartman,
Holy Shit,
right?
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
You know,
like crazy.
I was uh,
I like,
I like Rodney Dangerfield and uh,
did you ever hear that back to school?
When he got that script it was kind of a
Turd and the story goes that he took it
and he rewrote,
like he wrote jokes and all the margins
and then go and send it back to the
studio and they were like,
this is hilarious.
Can we make this movie?
He's like,
yeah,
you could pay me whatever,
$10,000
a joke and I'll look and do it that way.
Like,
that's awesome.
Do you like,
that's how fucking Dave Foley should
have been.
Like with Kevin Hart does with movies
where I'm like,
he has a,
a negotiation for the movie,
right?
They say,
oh,
we'll give you x amount of million
dollars to the movie.
And they go,
but we want you to promote it on your
social media.
Once you put on your twitter and your
answer is like,
Whoa,
oh yeah,
that's a different deal.
This is all my thing.
I built that up,
like,
if you want that,
you gotta give me my money for that.
That's what's up Kevin Hart.
And then they'll like what?
Like,
yeah,
but if the movie does well you.
No,
no,
no.
This was your mother fucking movie.
You're giving me money,
so if you want me to promote it on my
instagram,
my social media,
like that's a business.
He's built up a promotional business.
No,
that guy's a genius when it comes to
that.
Fantastic.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Fantastic.
Why not?
You should be compensated for that.
This you're following.
Especially him.
That's his whole deal.
So I mean most of what he became,
he became because it was comedy central,
special and then relentless social media
stuff.
Like really?
Yeah,
massive data and obviously he's really
funny.
Super Funny.
If you don't have talent,
he's one of the rare guys that has
talent and he's really good at
promotion.
Whereas most,
you know,
most of the people that are like really,
like there's a lot of people that are
good at promotion but they're not
talented.
Right.
You need to have some kind of meat for
the bone now.
Who is great at that though?
I mean the old gangster,
I've.
It was Dane Cook.
If you think back to a.
was it even like friends?
Yeah.
He was the first two.
He became famous through social media.
The first guy ever.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
But you have to have that in you,
I guess.
I remember reading a people magazine
article.
I was at the dentist and it was a people
magazine article that said the Dean had
250,000
followers and he's like,
what?
Why?
I was like,
that's insane.
It wasn't followers.
It was friends.
So many friends.
I don't even fucking know.
It's weird when you're like,
I do want to note that many people.
You know what's really crazy is that my
space just evaporated.
It did.
It got really weird.
It took a facebook took.
It took its place,
but my space still there,
like Jamie,
go to my space.
Taylor,
did Shirin Watch miley cyrus perform on
Carpool Karaoke on link and people love
that car.
Karaoke shell people.
Not,
not normal people.
No one.
That's healthy.
Shit sucks.
Why does everything suck?
It doesn't necessarily all suck.
A lot of.
It sucks a lot.
I mean I'm on the um,
the apple TV.
I try to,
I try to find stuff.
I'm like,
that's a fucking stupid.
The only thing that is interesting about
that is that they're actually in a car
and they're actually driving it.
Let them drive.
How do they film that?
They filled the Gopros and shit.
Like,
this is my space,
but this is so strange.
It's like,
who's on this motherfucker?
Who's going now?
It's like a news site.
Who are the people?
See if I'm on it.
Still.
Liz,
she's a musician.
Tried to.
I tried to delete my page long time ago
and they wouldn't let me get these
comedians.
I know all of them there.
These guys are top little fuck.
Are these people look like?
Come on,
look at that guy with the hair.
No,
I went to see him be super upset if we
didn't share funny comedy pictures ever.
In the beginning of your career,
the wackiest I took the stupidest
picture ever.
I had a fake mugshot picture with the
lipstick kisses on my face.
I think I tried to like put a bra in my
head too,
but so dumb.
Oh,
it's so embarrassing.
I had a business card.
Did you ever do that?
I never had a business card.
I don't.
Don't think I did and I hadn't paid.
It was a picture of me at four years old
making a funny face.
Those are so cute.
Yeah.
It's like it's painful.
It's so embarrassing now.
I now.
Yeah.
I don't have one.
Get One.
Yeah.
We signed a picture for Sonya.
I'm like,
you have a picture for me.
Took 1:20
years ago.
Pictures Man,
like ucf pictures at the comedy clubs
coming next week and they put up a
headshot.
I don't.
I don't even have one.
What do they put up with?
You have no idea.
They just find some shit online and they
print it.
We put it up,
but see that's how I feel now.
Like come on man,
I'm online.
Print that shit out.
It's all there.
You don't need to have my name at the
bottom of it and get the fuck out or you
can write that.
Like if I can sharpen it is the headshot
thing was always a big deal in Boston
because in Boston the there was like the
old guard does these guys that had been
around forever that will like the top
dogs in the local scene.
Those guys were like,
if you have a headshot you probably
fucking suck.
No one ever worked on their headshot.
Yeah,
like the young guys were all we have
like these new fancy headshots.
The old guys,
they didn't have anything.
They would just murder Steve Sweeney
plane at the cow saloon restaurant and
just murder.
No headshot.
Try to find a headshot album.
It's fucking faded.
You gotta pull it out of a window.
Was sitting there from the late
eighties,
so whoever had their shit together most
as an open miker was definitely the
unfunny.
Just like,
well,
there was a bunch of good.
You remember it probably wasn't around
when you were around,
but there was a thing called the comedy
USA industry guide.
No,
when I first started out there was a
thing called the comedy USA Industry
Guide and they would send it out to all
the industry and I was always like super
in awe of the guys that had a big page
and like a lot of it was like college
acts,
like a college act back then was.
That was the pinnacle.
That's what you wanted to be.
You want to be a college act because if
you were a college act you could make
like a thousand dollars a college or
$2,000
a college like Holy Shit and you would
think about,
oh my God,
I could do two colleges on a weekend and
make $4,000.
It was insane and I knew guys who were
doing it.
I knew guys who would manage clean your
act up so you can do colleges.
They will say that that that was the
best when I started to.
It was you got to clean it out.
Otherwise,
you're not going to get on the tonight
show,
you're not going to get on the thing,
and then the internet happened and
everybody was like,
fuck you,
and you're clean.
You know,
there's different outlets now.
You don't need to.
You know there's cable.
It's not,
it's just not the same.
And you know what's really gross to the
mediocre comic that suppresses the
talented guys that are coming up.
You ever seen those guys that like tell
you what to do,
what not to do?
Oh,
there was this one guy who was the host
of like open mic night in Boston at the
time and he was aggressively mediocre
because act was horrible,
but he was like,
you would,
you would go on stage and even if you
killed,
even if you had a good set,
he would shit on the fact that you had
to swear you're broke the fuck meter you
were up there breaking the fuck meter.
Like what?
Like,
you know,
you can't do that on TV is going to be a
lot of guys that are on TV and they're
going to be on TV and you're going to be
back here doing the same jokes saying
the fuck word all the time.
Like what?
And I was like,
well what about like the comics?
I like,
like Andrew dice clay or Sam kinison.
I got news for you,
man.
You're not dice clay to remind you where
you are on the,
on the totem pole.
But I was like,
well,
somebody like this is not,
this is not good advice.
No,
I remember being told back to with
comedy,
I think right now for,
for female comics,
I feel like right now there's a
particular dichotomy between like the
Madonna whore thing.
Like either you're,
you know,
young and hot and you're talking about
like sexual stuff or like you're me give
get fucking mom.
I'm talking about mom stuff.
Uh,
there's,
it's very,
it's different.
It's not like you can be just a person.
I don't think so right now,
but,
but why do you think that?
Because I think you can.
I think anybody can be a person if you
just own it,
you can.
It's an.
I don't know if.
I don't know.
I think it's the marketing and they
think it's just marketing.
See,
I just think you don't.
You don't see it?
I don't.
It's not that it can't be done.
I think people look at archetypes,
right?
They think like something that's already
been carved out.
Like Sarah Silverman.
She's pretty and she talks dirty.
I can do that.
I've seen that.
And you see like these,
you know,
patrice o'neal used to call them babies.
Like I got a lot of babies live comedy,
like,
you know,
these are my David tell got a lot of
comedy babies and David Taylor had a ton
of comedy babies because people would
imitate what they saw that was
successful,
saw that thing.
And you go,
oh,
I know that I can do like that.
I could talk like Dave.
And so there's these people that sort of
like imitated his cadence and rhythm and
it like some of them egregiously,
like some of them you're like,
Jesus Christ your bug.
Borderline a thief,
you know,
to.
It's easier for the audience to identify
a woman as a,
this is the one I have sex with or this
is not serious and I don't mean this as
like a,
a,
a woe is me,
like literally,
like,
it's just,
it just,
I feel is either there's women that you
fuck.
And then there's women that are,
that are off limits that are similar
maternal I leave.
That's been my experience in the comedy
world,
uh,
hanging out with dudes.
It was like the best thing that ever
happened to me was hooking up with Tom
Cigarette because it put like a magical
lasso,
have a limits flexibility.
And immediately one of the friends I
became a off limits per.
I became a person and it was great.
And I find that as I get older and
become more like less,
the fuckability stuff goes down.
I really like it.
I really liked just being a human,
uh,
where I was going to fucking go with
this.
Now I know what you're saying,
but do you think this is all in your own
head?
Yeah.
Maybe the all reality is right.
Aren't we all living in our own data
because a lot of these archetypes that
everybody sort of claims are
inescapable.
Then you'll see someone that doesn't fit
into that at all and you go,
oh,
well I didn't see that coming.
You know what I'm trying to think of
like the big,
the big female comics and they usually
either one or the other.
Right.
It's either a mommy or about ellen.
Very asexual,
right?
She's neither short hair and she's
probably a ton of posts.
Yes,
I would love.
Maybe she just gets her receipt and she
gets her toes done and it's a box and I
would love to hear her talk about eating
pussy and that be like my favorite thing
ever.
Wonder why don't she makes a face when
she posted,
maybe she,
not she,
but she came up.
Maybe she's super gross about it.
I think she's super gross,
I think.
I think it's the people that are super
one way publicly,
maybe privately.
She's real.
I've always thought about that about
comedians.
You know the nicey Nice ones.
Well,
not just the nicey nice ones,
but the over the top,
like defenders of women there turned out
to be super pervy.
We know a few of those always get
busted.
Like,
you know,
like there's people that you can trust,
like,
you know,
you know where you stand with Joey
Dia's.
Yeah,
no,
absolutely.
I love Julia and I trust him because I
know that's it.
Like I don't trust male comics that
don't talk about their dicks.
Are Jerking it,
jerking off her pussy and stuff.
What do you.
What's the fucking.
Yeah.
Where's your darker?
The shadow self or whatever.
As they say,
if you're not addressing the darkness,
the darkness comes out uh,
elsewhere,
right?
The dog.
The dog comes out of the places.
Yeah.
Like I always wonder what Jim Gaffigan's
freak shit is.
He's so clever.
I don't know.
He might be the exception to the rule be
right.
Because he's so nice family guy.
I think he really likes being a failure.
I don't,
I don't sense that shit from him.
Put cosby.
Oh God was this,
that was a surprise.
Yeah.
Was it though?
Did you.
Did you ever hear the rumors?
No.
See I did in show business circles
because,
uh,
briefly I lived in the actor's world
right when I was on news radio and I
would hear it and hear it back then that
he would drug people.
Really?
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Yeah,
you would hear it.
It was like one of those weird rumors
that would go around bill cosby drugs,
people,
dude,
what's going on forever.
That's why Hannah,
when Hannah talked about it on stage and
then it all blew up,
which is kind of crazy if you go
Hannibal,
you know,
because he just happened to be talking
about it and then someone happened to be
filming it and then the rest of the
world was like,
is that true?
Is that true?
Because bill cosby's always telling
people to not swear talent.
Especially like he was big on telling
young black comedians not swear enough
to talk about sex and he's like,
he goes,
Bill cosby and until now at least I'm
not raping people.
And everybody's like,
what?
What?
That was like.
The rumor
was always around.
I didn't,
I,
I had heard some creepy,
a little creepiness,
the,
but I didn't know,
but it was that extent when someone,
when someone does something like that to
people,
like that's one of the,
like
that's one of the creepiest fucking
things a human can do to another human.
Yeah.
And the idea that this guy who was
America's father,
right.
And a lot of ways he was our black dad,
you know,
he was the moral authority.
He was,
he was Mr Huxtable.
Yeah.
You know,
and then the fact that that guy,
someone described him as the biggest
serial rapist in the history of America,
like that really might be the case
because if he really did drug all these
people that he said he did,
like how many people have raped more?
He might be number one.
One,
which is crazy.
Insane.
It's crazy.
And the whole time.
And he's the darkest motherfucker ever
darken.
Start drugging them,
watching them plastic fucking.
And he's got kids even more fucked up.
The crazy part was drug use or someone
else's baby and sticking his dick and
um,
other unconscious.
It's so evil.
It's evil.
Now,
what about Harvey Weinstein?
And he's won.
Everyone knew about two apparently.
Apparently.
Yeah.
That's the um,
looks like.
Does the Cliche,
right?
The disgusting boss of the studio that
wants you to suck his dick to get a
role.
I know it's funny because you do think
like,
well,
isn't that kind of why you become like a
show business executive to get chicks
not to rape chicks.
Sexual assault is always off the table,
but,
but did he rape them or did.
Now it's coming out that there's,
there's rape at last I checked today.
Uh,
I know he's,
and he is not a looker,
like he's definitely the type of guy
that would be the type of guy he is,
which is what's fucked up.
Suicide threat prompts.
Police response.
Whoa.
Were there,
Huh?
Fight with his daughter this morning.
And they had to.
She called the nine one one damn.
Because he was gonna kill himself or
something.
I don't know.
It must be so overwhelmed with guilt and
fear and remorse and just self hatred
and you know,
he sounds like an addict,
you know?
Yeah.
And that he's also a probably a power
addict,
you know,
like he's this guy who's like this
gluttonous man.
Like if you look at his physical self,
right,
his face is over,
flowing on his collar and he's just
gluttonous food.
Where's the plus?
There's this gluttonous existence.
It's not like a measured thought out
contemplatives introspective existence
where he's just trying to enjoy his time
here.
Like wow,
how lucky I am that I get to do this and
make these amazing movies.
You guys were all great.
That's,
I expect from like Steven Spielberg,
Steven Spielberg to be like this really
like introspective,
thoughtful guy.
I was just enjoying the process of
making amazing movies,
but he's a creative thing.
Harvey's and Executive Guy,
right?
He's the guy,
the money guy behind everything and Vr,
something like that.
It is so nasty.
So gross.
But okay.
Now on the other hand,
on the other hand,
I was like,
you know,
Hollywood is such a labyrinth in terms
of like getting shit done and getting
deals closed.
And how did this,
does this happen?
It would kind of be nice to be like,
you want to Netflix special,
just go fucking suck,
and then I can be like,
oh,
that's all I have to do.
It's something that guys come over here,
you nasty.
Fuck.
And then there's your special right?
Way Easier would you have to have a
conversation with Tommy?
Listen Tommy,
this is not sex work.
Right?
And then it's like cut and dry and it's
an exchange.
You know,
I was in law school for two weeks and I
remember two weeks,
two weeks and I dropped out in contract
law.
It's an exchange of something for
something else.
Seems fucking pretty straightforward.
Well that's what prostitution is,
right?
Because one of the weirdest things that
massage is legal,
but prostitution isn't.
Isn't that something?
It is.
It is odd because we do not like genital
pleasure,
not like genital pleasure for cash,
like general pleasure has to be for love
and be loved,
right?
It has to be given free is the only
thing in civilization that we require to
be given away for free.
Everything else you can exchange money
for.
It's an interesting change.
Money for food,
right?
It's not prostitution.
If someone cooks for you,
right.
That's normal.
So total normal thing,
but it's a very intimate thing.
Feeding someone.
Yes,
yes,
of course.
It's a hair salon.
The wash your head to give you a head
massage.
For one thing I miss about having hair
rubbed my head.
Oh,
it's the best feeling in the world.
Massage or foot massage.
People love foot massages.
I bet there's people out there that like
foot massages more than than like head,
but yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
Right.
But then you put a camera in front of
two people.
Fucking totally illegal.
Now it's legal.
You're paying pam.
So what's were retarded.
Yeah,
that makes no sense.
Babies were grown up babies because you
can commodify that and that's a
capitalistic thing.
Maybe it's more commodifiable as a
product is.
Absolutely.
I think there's two factors.
One is the tax factor.
It's very difficult to get taxes from
people that are prostitutes,
right?
It's like,
no,
none of that.
Where's that money going?
Give us,
give us our cut.
And then the other thing is the sex
trafficking,
sex slavery aspect,
like protecting people that are sex
traffickers because like,
you know,
you could have someone that was sold
into sex slavery or you know,
in some way bartered their trip to
America,
had some sort of a sex slave deal.
That's where it gets fucked up.
But there has been arguments that what
makes that exists in the first place.
Is it prostitution is illegal here and a
prostitution was legal.
It would be.
That stuff would all go away.
Much like the argument is with illegal
drugs,
like if you made marijuana legal,
you wouldn't have as much of the Mexican
drug trade,
which you are seeing,
you are seeing in America.
Of course it's retarded and a wait.
But wait,
Harvey,
he was the guy that would give girls the
shoulder rubs.
He would tell them to massage him.
Oh,
he was massage them,
did massage him.
He would do according to these girls.
I don't know if it's true,
but he would.
He'd be the guy that I'll be right back
and he comes back in a bathrobe bathrobe
guy.
So here's the thing.
Here's the thing,
I don't mean to make light of anybody's
sexual assault or whatever it was or
harassment,
but other working on the roof again,
wonderful,
but,
but what I.
But here's the thing,
how many women said yes,
that's a fuck load.
Like that was his move.
What we're seeing is his missed pitches,
right?
Right.
He hit a lot of fucking triples and home
runs,
knocked a lot of balls out of the park,
but occasionally he was whipping
occasionally.
He was like,
I got this one in the back boys and
she's like,
fuck off you pig.
And he's like,
ah,
come on.
Just come back to my room.
No,
no,
no.
Just like,
shut down.
What happened?
Harvey just wasn't connecting.
I wasn't connecting,
but listen,
I got all this girl wants to be in the
next [inaudible],
this movie and the Avatar.
16.
Willing to do the thing to get the part
and that's kind of okay.
Yeah.
Then then like that guys,
they can get the part and get your money
and get on with it.
How many girls read the story when it
broke and could still taste the
asparagus?
Caviar flavored come just the cocaine
and vodka in his loads and I bet he has
like a Flemmi like Moan when he comes.
He's a kind of get sleep.
Yes.
Battle in the corners of his mouth.
When he talked to you trying to hit on
you.
He's got a little bit bubble lip.
He nasty,
nasty,
nasty.
That's a gluttonous man right out of
control.
It's not attractive.
It's definitely not at all.
My favorite too is that he would jerk
off into.
Did you hear this?
But he plants was green.
He wants to exist off of his loads but
that's such a desperate thing.
Like come over.
Can we get it?
Can I have it?
No.
Okay.
You stay here then let me,
you know,
like it's.
So
maybe it was hoping they would just dive
on a grenade.
Gave a soldier.
But I know so
like I was thinking too.
Look,
I've,
I've seen so many dudes jerking off in
public like homeless guys.
I never got anything for it.
Is it?
You know,
good point.
Yeah.
You guys look,
here's the thing about male versus
female sex,
right?
Is the accepting part of female sex
versus the giving,
like trying to get,
take this,
take it.
And the other thing is that men take it
literally or constantly building come
while you're alive.
You come as backing up,
so if you're,
if you're not like I used to have the
bit in my art,
that was,
it was really based on advice that I
used to give friends when they're like,
oh no girl wants to get marines.
I listened me jerk off first and then
think about it like if you're,
if you're having a hard time with
someone and you're,
you don't know what to do and you're
going to see them jerk off first and
then see them and then you'll be able to
deal with them without any sexual lust.
You won't make it because of me.
As far as a young man,
this is a real issue with me when I was
in my twenties because I was so horny,
it was like I was a drug addict so I'd
be like,
oh,
it'd be like making agreements with
myself.
Yeah,
she's annoying,
but she's going to let me have sex with
her,
so listen,
just let's just change our behavior and
mold to what she likes and then you'll
get the fucker is that's what you need.
Like otherwise just be beating off.
But I remember one time I was supposed
to go out with this girl and she was
just so preposterously annoying.
It was so frustrating.
She just was always negative and before
we went out,
before I went to go get her,
I jerked off and I was sitting there.
I was going,
what am I doing?
Like I don't even enjoy her company.
She's not compatible with me.
Like I don't if you can,
if you would just like someone as a
person and you like having sex with
them.
That's a relationship.
But if you only like having sex with
them,
you have some sort of a weird bartered
deal and that's a lot of men.
A lot of men get in and I'm sure a lot
of women probably too,
but I can only speak for men like men
get involved in these relationships
where you're really just in a
relationship.
So that you have a continuous supply of
sex,
especially when you're young and stupid.
When you're 20 years old,
you're basically a monkey.
You know,
you're,
you're just like a little eight person
just trying to fuck and you just try to
love her.
She's really cool.
And why do you love her?
Because she smells good because her tits
feel good in your mouth.
Like what?
What is really going on?
Do you actually enjoy her company as a
human being outside of sex?
It doesn't matter,
right?
Most of the time you don't.
And so if you could just jerk off first
and then hang out with someone you
actually liked them,
like then you have a real relationship.
Like oh I really like you.
Like,
like you clear out the pipes,
clear out the testosterone and think
clearly super smart.
But I think,
I mean I'm just guessing.
I've never been a media mogul,
but I would imagine there's a bunch of
factors going on.
First of all,
there's a bunch of people that are
constantly kissing his ass and rubbing.
Like I saw a picture him with Renee
Zellweger and Renee Zellweger was like
cuddling up with them and she had her
hand on him and he had his arm on her
and there was some other celebrity to
his right and there were like,
Yuck,
Yuck it up.
But he was like pawn her.
He had a hold of her and I would imagine
that there's all these people that
recognize that he's just like epicenter
of power and success and you want Harvey
Weinstein of Miramax to love you and you
would get close to him and you have a
couple of drinks and you're doing coke
together.
Yeah,
look at that.
She's got her hand on his leg and he's
got Russell Crowe to his right and Renee
Zellweger to his left and she's smiling.
They're probably hammered and everyone's
on Xanax.
Next scene.
Now he's got his dick in her butt.
That's crazy,
dude.
She's imagining Jones' diary number two,
number six.
Correct.
Fine with me.
I don't know if that really happened,
but my point is that it's not just that
he was predatory,
it was also that he lived.
I'm just guessing.
Okay,
I'm not an apologist folks,
but I would imagine that he lived in
this world where he was like royalty.
He was essentially like the king of this
empire.
Right.
So you had all these employees is one of
the articles that I read today,
I think it was from the Telegraph where
this guy was saying that,
um,
he was at a party or one of his friends
was at a party and they were having a
conversation with this girl who worked
for Harvey and Harvey just set her name
from across the room and her face went
pale and she immediately just ran away
from him to run to her.
Like didn't say,
excuse me,
I'll be right back.
Just ran at a fear.
Who knows?
That is obvious.
It.
Can he be interpretation after the fact.
It could be exaggeration of what the
actual circumstances were to fit a
narrative,
but you got to imagine that this guy is
just multimodal tie millionaire.
Just orgiastic,
gluttonous.
Jabba the Hutt motherfucker just getting
as.
And we're going to be the biggest,
the biggest driver.
And then there's also these girls he
can't get and he's like close to them,
close to the anger.
Right?
Listen Christina,
you're the one that he cut his hand on
you.
One of the best when they come into my
room.
Let's talk about this.
A proposal.
I've got a proposal.
You come up to his room,
he's got a bathrobe on.
You're like,
what?
Just give me a massage.
My neck is tense.
I'm not going to send you like coke.
What about cocaine?
Caviar,
cocaine carrier altogether that is.
He is unbelievably him and I have to
say,
and I know Hugh hefner was a big mogul
and he did a lot of cool shit.
Not For me.
That would be a tough gig to like living
in the mansion and being one of the
girls come over for movie night,
you know,
and he's in his pajamas and you know
that he bought them because
he didn't want to get anyone pregnant.
So that's what I read in.
What is it?
Holly Holly Madison wrote,
I wrote a book.
Is that her name is Dolly Madison.
Is the pastry like who the fuck is that?
They didn't have to worry about birth
controls.
Correct.
And then there's a lot of like he,
he would make the girls make out in
front of him and then he would
masturbate too.
It's also kind of,
I think is a way of avoiding possible
pregnancies.
So we developed a strategy over year.
They're like ducking pregnancies.
Wow.
That's,
that's a weird thing to write,
to be putting yourself out there as this
person with a lot of money who really
loves young girls and the young girls
go.
All I have to do is catch one load at
the right time.
Stories about athletes that girls put
holes in the condoms or the girl girls
take the condoms out of the trash and
score them into their posting.
Imagine.
How was I born,
Mommy?
Well,
it's a lovely story.
Umami Umami took a condom like one of
the pastry bags and quarter that fucker
in.
Well your mother fish to filthy condom
out of the trash.
I tended to throw it in the toilet,
but I had one saved in my mouth.
Spit that one in the toilet and that's
why you're alive.
Wild wild.
But then I heard that the playboy
mansion,
she wrote that it was run down and uh,
they had like bunk beds and shit in the
rooms and like,
it's not,
it wasn't as glamorous as everybody.
I couldn't touch factor fear factor
playmate edition.
And I was like,
Huh,
this is it.
I got to go see that at the grotto was
um,
there were the people that worked there
were very nice.
The girls were very nice,
but there's like a,
there's a thing that you're experiencing
where it's like they don't have a whole
lot of options.
So it's like it's an option for them to
be a part of this.
And some of them loved it for sure.
Some of them it was what they wanted.
And for some of them there's like a
sadness to it.
It's like.
And it's also some of them when we did
fear factor,
like some of them were like older
playmates,
so they've been playmates like 10 years
ago or 15 years.
So they were like pushing 30 and maybe
even older.
They're like,
what am I going to do soon?
Like what am I going to do in five
years,
what am I going to do in 10 years?
And then there's not a lot of answers on
the horizon.
So they'll go looking for maybe some old
rich husband type character or maybe
some way out financially,
you know,
maybe have some business that they can
start,
you know,
some clothing line,
like everyone's got a hustle and a scam,
but they essentially don't really have a
career.
They have like this sort of like opening
into this world.
And then they would have the mansion
parties.
Right.
Which I,
I went to one for the marijuana policy
project.
I hosted this thing,
this event.
It was,
it was very weird.
It was like they have bands playing and
stuff and you're just walking around and
just pot everywhere and everyone's
stoned out of their mind.
It was,
it was an extra surreal because of the
pot factor.
But like you go by where,
where he had pets.
It's like birds and monkeys and shit.
Like what the fuck is this place?
Everybody's high as fuck,
but it's just the,
the,
and there was no playmates for that one.
That was weird because that was one of
the ones you rent out and so lecherous
guys went there.
They will go to the mainland.
They rented it out.
Sweets?
No,
no.
They rent out the use of the mansion.
Yeah.
So you can use the garage.
You can come in the grotto where
everyone else comes.
General public want to jerk off in the
grotto.
I don't know if they actually let people
in the grotto.
When I was.
I don't remember.
It was quite a long time ago,
but I do remember like the,
the grotto had this phone from like the
19 seventies old ass fucked up fondly.
The upkeep on a place like that.
It's probably super expensive.
There's the phone look it up,
old wack ass phone and all the buttons
for the lights and Shit and you know,
he wasn't going to put money into
renovating that shit because he was old.
He was like,
I'm dying.
I also think there wasn't money.
I don't think that the mansion,
the mansion was a location that actually
made money,
right,
because it was like a destination and
they would rent it out for stuff,
but I don't think the magazine was
making money.
I think the magazine was really
struggling once the Internet happened
and you can get pornography for free and
you can actually see everything.
The whole thing.
Yeah.
Why?
Why buy playboy?
Like the.
Oh,
I can say purely can just see when they
took the.
They took nudity out for like a whole
year.
What are you talking about?
They did,
yes,
because they were.
They were getting crazy.
They're like,
we're going to be maximum show girls.
Okay.
Carousel.
He did for a little while and just the
sales tanked.
The crashed even maximum smack,
you know,
on a military base in the British ones
that they let them look at Teddy mags.
Like they can get maximum magazine and
stuff.
Not The American military does not allow
you to look at Teddy mags and the
American military has a very high rate
of sexual assault.
Do you know that?
I've been to the Middle East,
Afghanistan and a lot of those bases and
I've heard bad stories is apparently a
giant issue that is very suppressed
because you're not dealing with like law
in terms of like civilian law.
You're dealing with like military law.
So yeah,
I don't.
I don't know what the real numbers are,
but I've read quite a few stories about
that's a real issue.
If you don't give them an outlet,
you know you have a bunch of people who
are watching their friends heads get
blown up.
That's the thing you're on.
Your whole reality is out the window
when you're at war,
and I'm not excusing anyone for sexual
assault,
but I'm saying like the world that
you're living in at home and then you
are in Afghanistan and bullets are
whizzing by.
Who knows what.
These kids
go.
Their kids,
right?
Who knows what the fuck they learned
back home.
Who knows what their situation is,
who knows if they got into the army as
some sort of a parole deal is that.
That happens with a lot of guys as well.
I know guys that had to go in the army
or go to jail.
Yes,
I heard that in the navy.
They take a lot that they used to do
those deals a lot.
Yeah,
they did those deals.
It's Kinda good though.
I mean,
when you think about it,
I would choose military over.
Yeah,
go put me in the boat.
I don't know if I'm Joe.
Fuck.
Yeah.
I think you're right.
I think because I was in Kuwait I think
and they were talking about,
you know,
guys coming out of active battle and
they're,
they're just so whacked out and I think
that's what happens when they assault
women and stuff.
They don't.
Who knows?
It's crazy.
You also have ptsd.
You also have cte which leads to
impulsive behavior and cte or even know
what that is.
Chronic traumatic encephalopathy in
sample.
Opposite.
And how was the actual word of Patheon?
Cephalopathy.
It's brain damage.
Oh my God.
Essentially it's what football players
get.
Would boxers get MMA fighters,
get it?
People with head injuries and one of the
things that is a part of that is that
you get impulsive and you do irrational
things,
thoughtless things,
and you almost like you can't help
yourself.
And um,
they,
they think that it's a responsible for
erratic changes in behavior,
violent behavior amongst athletes that
have it,
especially football players.
You see like some of the,
like really aggressive,
fucked up things with football players
have done.
Like they attribute some of it to cte.
Yeah.
It's terrible.
We are the NFL in 1960.
Two researchers say the professional
bull rider have killed himself at cte.
Oh,
not today because.
Yeah,
of course.
Of course.
You're writing a fucking 2000 pound
monster animal.
Do you have his balls tied up in a knot?
Do you,
have you,
uh,
have you ever done like the military
stuff during it in,
in an active war zone?
No,
it's fucking I,
I went to Afghanistan a few years ago,
like in.
Oh seven or something.
I can't do it again.
I was so,
it's so.
It's so nutty.
You're right.
And it's boys.
It's like 19 year old boys that are just
getting blown up,
stepping on IED like I go visit boys and
in hospitals with shrapnel in their
faces and and the crazy part is the guys
that are injured,
they feel bad that they're not out
fighting next to.
They're fighting with their company or
whatever.
They feel guilty that they're not still
out there and you're like,
oh,
have you ever read a Sebastian younger?
You ever read any of his stuff?
He's got a great book called tribe and
it's a lot of it is about what happens
to people in times of war and what
happens to soldiers,
the comradery that they share together
and that even though these harrowing
death filled moments of their life,
that when they look back at it,
it was their favorite time of life.
Isn't that interesting?
Yeah,
because people apparently his.
I mean a lot of people believe this,
that people extreme struggled,
don't find meaning in life and that the
dull gray cubicle life stuck in traffic,
eating fast food,
watching TV,
going to sleep by.
That is the torture.
That's the torturous existence,
not the existence of of battle and the
comradery that they share when the
soldiers are side by side fighting for
their lives and and defending each
other.
The comraderies incredibly intense
and the emotions are incredibly high.
I would imagine too that that high
stakes your life is at stake,
dude,
and you have to take care of each other
and that's so true.
There is nothing more depressing than
the gray,
the grays,
the board,
the of Sisyphean and thing like they're
pull up,
push the rock up,
and then the rock come like that.
Zach elevator music.
Yeah,
that's absolutely true.
The drone,
the drone of and nothing existence.
It's just.
I mean that is what most people sell
their time for the.
They sell their eight hours everyday
plus commuting to the drone time.
Just droning on and there are a lot of
people.
A lot of those people are listening to
this right now and one of the things
about podcasts that's amazing for,
for that is like people get a chance to
hear the way other people live and think
and then realize like there is a way
out.
I am alive,
I'm alive and my brain is working and I
can think and even though I'm stuck here
because I have to pay my bills,
this is not permanent.
I need to figure out my exit strategy
and I need to start moving on it now and
they start doing that and that that's,
that's a,
that's a huge factor in people's futures
to hear the fact that other people have
been stuck.
I'm,
no,
you have been stuck.
He was ducking shit job.
Yeah,
I mean I fucking did it.
I had 22 jobs in four years when I
graduated from college.
Yeah.
I had a fucking philosophy degree and
that was totally useless and I tried
everything before I became a standard
training.
You name it dude.
Dog Walker.
Parking attendant,
a production assistant.
I worked in a cannery.
I've done it.
I like cannery.
The cannery in Chatsworth.
I worked in a cannery.
Lillian cans like these cans here?
Yeah,
like Laverne and Shirley were to the
beer thing whenever I worked in a
cannery.
Very,
very short drop because I wanted to know
what the world was about.
I didn't know what the world was about
and I didn't know that I.
I just didn't fit in anywhere.
I was a paralegal.
I was an immigration paralegal,
corporate paralegal like I,
and at the time you didn't need to have
any kind of like accreditation.
You just had to have an attorney say
that you were and so I just learned it
was fucking crazy.
Yeah.
Prenup attorney says,
Yup,
here's your stamp.
You can be an immigration paralegal
because I worked long enough now.
Right now.
Now you need to get a certain occasion.
Yeah.
I'm A.
I'm a minister.
You are.
I'm an ordained minister.
Congratulations.
That's phenomenal.
I did it online.
He did.
How long did it take?
Five minutes.
Training yet?
There was no training.
Yeah,
no,
of course.
I just an ascendance of money.
I don't remember long ago.
I'm married some people though.
You did?
Yeah.
Married these two people.
That one fear factor really nice.
Couple married them.
It's nice of you to do.
People ask us to marry them and we're
like,
I don't know that I do it again.
Since then I'm like,
nope.
I'm wanting to know and I think they're
still together so that's good.
Worked out bitch,
but as an addendum to what you were just
saying about that cubicle life,
that gray life and I don't know if this
is a function of like turning 40 for me,
but I've had this thing lately where I'm
really acutely aware of my death.
Like I've always been very existential,
like I've always loved thinking about my
death because it frees me to be alive,
but now at 40 1:41
and I'm like,
well I feel like I'm knocking on death's
door.
I like,
I get this weird thing of like it's so
short,
like you don't really have a lot of time
on this planet and it's really weighing
on me now more.
Especially now that I have a child and
I'm like,
I just want to stay alive to see my son
grow up.
But then you realize like,
how much of your life are you going to
fucking piss away doing shit you don't
want to do working in the fucking
cubicle job you don't want to have like
you don't.
You don't get many years.
Do you want me to eat?
You don't get many great years,
right?
When is your body starts to really take
a shit like 70
when you're 70,
you're fucking rough.
Seventies.
A rough thing like you have a lot of bad
days.
I would imagine.
I think one of the big keys,
and this is very hard for people to
imagine that don't enjoy exercise is
exercise is not an option.
It's a necessity.
It's a necessity for body maintenance.
So all these people go,
oh,
I don't want to work out.
Oh Shit.
No.
I just,
I'd rather just eat whatever I want and
live I live and you know,
roll the dice and be fine.
No,
it doesn't.
You don't just have a heart attack and
die.
You slowly rot away and then your body
gives out.
Yeah.
Like it's not a quick and easy process.
It's not like you and you,
you the quality of your time is not the
same.
The quality of your time with exercise
is far superior than the quality of your
time without exercise because you're,
you're more relaxed.
He body functions better,
you're stronger,
you can do things,
you know,
you don't have to be helped in so many
ways.
Like there's a lot of people that can't
even open up a jar of pickles.
You know,
there's like,
their body is just not good.
It's not working good.
You know,
that's.
You don't want to be that person.
I'm not saying you should be a
bodybuilder or these should have a six
pack.
You don't have to do that,
but you should devote a certain amount
of time per week for body maintenance
and you'll feel better.
It'll give you better decision making
abilities.
You'll,
you'll,
you'll be calmer.
You'll be more removed from the stress
of the everyday grind because your
body's experiencing some stress,
some workload.
And by doing that and putting out that
energy,
it frees you.
Oh my gosh,
can I just tell you that I've met so
many people on the road,
um,
who come up to me and say,
please tell Joe Rogan,
thank you.
Because I lost 100 pounds because I've
been listening to him.
I lost 50 pounds.
I started exercising because I've been
listening to Joe and Dah,
Dah,
so just know that people totally
listened to neal and totally have
changed our lives.
A lot of responsibility,
but uh,
but yeah,
I don't fucking like polities I hate it,
but to anybody listening that hates it
the way I do than pay somebody,
pay somebody who holds you accountable
and then you have to fucking show up and
they,
they make you do it.
Just don't just go and pay somebody.
You know what?
And here's the thing,
when people who don't have any money,
if you can listen to this podcast,
it means you have a computer,
right?
Hopefully if you have a computer or if
you have a phone,
if you have a regular iphone or
something like that,
you can go on youtube and you could play
a yoga class.
There's a ton of them.
You don't need to pay to pay.
I mean,
hot yoga I think is better because it's
like more strain in your body.
But guess what?
Regular Yoga is fine.
It's fucking great for,
you know,
Youtube.
Yeah.
It's all in all.
Also for bodyweight exercises.
I tell people that when they want to
know kettlebell exercises,
like yeah,
if you can afford to have someone teach
you how to do it correctly,
that's good,
but you can learn everything you want to
learn on youtube.
It's not amazing.
It's incredible.
Unclogged drain one time from Youtube,
from Youtube.
I was like,
we didn't have any money and the battle
was full and fucked up and I was like,
I'm not going to pay some fucking guy to
come here and just snake this thing and
then that's it.
And I learned how to do it.
I went down to the hardware store,
got the thing,
but to do it,
but if it got one of those,
once I got one of them power snakes,
that's great.
Fucking snake the shit out of my,
my watch my dogs in the shower and it
was just caked up with hair.
It was ridiculous.
I had just like,
Hey,
our Pi.
But like I would pull it out of the
drain like these big wads.
Especially Brutus.
My,
um,
my Shiba Inu,
I'm a English bulldog mix.
He's got a lot of hair.
And when I would watch him in the
shower,
I would pull these hunks and Marshall's
the worst though the goldens that worse.
You pull these giant chunks,
people's hair logged everything up.
So I just got one of them.
Snakes shoved it in there and it
follows.
It's weighed down and cleans it all out.
And then the water flushes don't pump
that drain.
Oh shit down there though.
That eats away your pipes,
right?
It's not good.
You know what I was thinking I should
have fucking become like a plumber or an
electrician while I was doing standup in
the beginning,
like as a day job because I for when
some shit happens at your house and you
got to call that asshole and they come
out,
they have all the power.
The guy who knows how to just fix your
plumbing or your electricity is not a
small job.
It's not easy.
I'm not saying that.
But the guy that knows how to do that
has all the power in that situation.
And you're so vulnerable,
you know,
and your lights don't work or the thing
and you're like,
Oh,
you have the knowledge of the power to
do this,
please help me.
So you think you should've become a
plumber just to learn it so that you can
do for yourself or to do it as a Gig.
That should've been my daytime job.
But if you do that as a Gig,
that's not an easy gig to get.
It's not easy.
You to have an apprenticeship.
You learn how to deal with the union has
a lot of shit involved and you know what
skill it is.
But it's also super long hours.
Like you're working,
you're working hard like plumbers work,
you know.
But it's the long hours.
I was hoping I could make my own hours a
bit more.
Well,
and the good thing about something like
that though is you would have your
nights free.
That's what I'm talking about.
You'd be so tired.
You need a lazy day job.
That's what I found for standup.
It was the best just to have like a nine
to five that I didn't give a shit about.
Didn't have to expend too much energy.
What was your.
What would your nine to five job that
you were when you first started making
it first started working?
Well,
the best job I ever had was at the girl
scouts of Greater Los Angeles.
That's the fucking fun.
As John was part time and I would like
help the girl scout cookie drive sale.
I would answer phones and I was on
Chelsea lately at the same time,
so I would go to the round table and
then go work at the girl scouts like the
next day.
That's crazy.
Yeah,
it was fun.
It was fun though.
It was like an easy paycheck.
Let girls in the cub scouts now?
Yes.
Now is it vice versa to the cub scouts
are going to join the girl scouts.
I don't think any boys are going to sign
up for the law.
Why?
How dare you?
How Binary?
Super Binary about my son.
Uh Oh.
We're.
We're so binary in our house.
We just bought my son a football,
a football book.
It's in the shape of a football and
explains football to the boy.
You should do that.
And right next to it,
put a little dress and see which one to
choose.
I can't.
I fucking tell you right now.
When he chooses.
It's so.
It's so funny now that I have a son and
I'm like,
this is the kid likes dirt.
He's playing in the trash can right now.
All that stuff.
Cars,
dirt,
muck.
He's 100 percent heterosexual.
He might be just like a super bare.
Yeah,
that'd be great.
And muffled bear.
I like that character because if he's.
Tommy's boy's going to be hairy as fuck
Harry.
And you'd do it a wolf.
Imagine if he's a little baby and he
starts growing back here.
You're like,
oh,
you're a baby.
What the fuck has jamie wants to babies
with back here?
There's got to be like some Iranian
wrestler,
baby,
Iranian,
Russian man.
Lead little baby with fucking thick back
here.
It's hilarious.
Like what is the youngest ever child
that had been?
Okay,
there's got to be some weird genetic
thing.
Like hirsutism.
Yeah.
Here you go.
Go Harry fucking baby.
Jesus Christ is that babies pass.
Ever clean.
The hairiest baby ass ever.
That's incredible baby.
A kid's got no shot,
literally going to live with your
werewolf.
Oh,
look at that Harry fucking baby.
That's the same.
That baby's entire back is covered in
hair care.
That's a kid's going to be a savage.
I bet he's built like Wolverine.
Yeah.
It's probably like seven.
Just shacked pig traps and shit.
Giant shoulders covered with a for.
Yeah.
We took my son to some baby heavy
classes,
you know,
and they teach whatever they say shit.
Like we're stimulating his frontal lobe
right now.
Right.
He's bouncing balls.
It's called bouncing the fucking ball
and then she brings out a box of dolls
and there's girls and boys in the class
and my son is like night and interested.
That shit.
Like he just totally doesn't want it.
And then she tells me,
you know,
we should teach him to like adults too
and also be sensitive.
And I'm like,
don't worry about it.
Yeah.
First of all,
my kids not interested.
He's not going to lie.
I'm not gonna force him to play.
Secondly,
he knows how to be gentle.
We have dogs in the house.
He,
he learns to be.
He's not a stupid idiot kid like,
you know,
but the forcing of it,
I was like,
all right,
well we know fucking whatever.
Not Weird that someone,
first of all the,
the idea that you would know what a
child should play with at two and you
this person who doesn't even know the
kid.
Right.
And does she have babies of her own?
I don't know.
Eh,
I probably should know that too.
So this is like theoretical shit that
she's trying to apply to a living human
in some sort of experimental way and
teaching it as dogma.
Yes,
I know.
And it's always the bitches that don't
have kids,
so it's always a weird fucking macrame
bitches.
I smelled like petroleum fucking incense
and they drive Prius's.
It's so great.
Bumper stickers.
Oh,
that's cute.
They're choking those babies,
baby spawn Australia babies get massages
and stuff.
Oh,
that's Kinda cool.
Kid smiling,
you know,
it's really creepy baby chiropractors
that.
Yeah,
they take their babies to chiropractors
and the chiropractors adjust them.
I was like,
yeah,
cracked her next newborn babies.
Not enough money in the world.
Out of their fucking mind.
Yeah.
I would never do it fucking sick.
How do you even find a school for your
chiropractic for you?
Get can help with colic,
earaches reflux,
asthma,
allergies,
sleep problems,
adhd and bed wedding,
and it makes them psychic.
You can see the future.
They read your mind,
shut the fuck up.
It doesn't do any of those things.
You fucking assholes.
Baby.
Crack and cons that that is the one of
the creepiest fucking things and this is
the other thing to have the best
possible start.
Everything is marketed that if you don't
do this for your child,
they're going to be developmentally
behind every other asshole.
Well,
I have to tell you,
I've known the human race now for 41
years.
I'm not fucking impressed and I'm not
worried that my kid is behind all these
assholes because most people aren't
really doing much anyway,
so I'm not so worried about getting
ahead.
He's fine by cracking his neck.
Yeah.
He needs his fucking net zero evidence
that does anything by the way,
zero.
I don't know
about it.
Do know about it unfortunately.
Yeah.
I went into it.
I had a lady on was written articles
about it.
It was all invented by a guy who was a
magnetic healer in the 18 hundreds.
It's one of those things.
It's grandfathered in that we'd like to
think of as being legit source of
medicine.
Like they call themselves.
Doctors didn't go to medical school,
medical school.
It's something like they put leaches on
you.
Not that kind of.
Well,
it's just leaches might actually have a
medical benefit,
but the only thing that seems to help is
adjusting lower back for some people,
alleviate some pain,
but the problem is is like some
psychosomatic shit going on with people.
There's some placebo effect.
Like does that feel better?
Yeah,
it does.
I like you're looking forward to feel
better.
Just being touched feels better now.
Getting a massage feels better,
but there's no like one,
like,
look,
if you go to an orthopedic surgeon,
you have a tear in your knee.
They replace your acl.
That's fucking real.
They really fixed.
You know,
if someone just takes you,
it goes,
okay,
relax.
I want you to think about your shock or
about the sun.
I'm going to get.
Hold on.
I'm gonna.
Get it.
Okay.
I got it.
You didn't get anything get and it's
terrifying.
It's terrifying to have somebody do that
to,
you know,
girl died last year,
some playboy playmate she character.
She got adjusted and she developed some
sort of a blood clot and died.
Cool.
And in someone,
someone I talked about that and people
that love chiropractors or are
chiropractors,
they emailed me.
You fucking asshole.
You're splitting a negative shit about
chiropractic.
That woman had a medical issue that she
did not dissolve.
Just listened to me.
If she can get through life and not have
a fucking stroke until someone adjust
her neck.
How the hell is adjusting your neck?
Good.
She had a medical issue.
What?
What medical issue?
She doesn't like getting her neck
strangled.
Like what?
What is going on?
She did.
She bleed easy,
but she hemophiliac.
Like what's causing why?
Why you're doing that?
There's no evidence that that works.
It doesn't do anything.
I don't know.
I don't know shit about it.
I don't trust it though.
I don't let anybody fucking crack me.
It's crazy how,
how prominent it is.
It's everywhere.
We had a girl tell us when our son was
eight weeks old and he was crying like
around 5:00
every night.
It's like it was his witching hour.
Newborns often have the time of day.
They get cranky.
She goes,
this is our,
our nanny at the time.
She goes,
you know,
I,
I sent this energy is off and it might
be because he's sensing your anxiety
and.
Well,
I have a friend that does Reiki and um,
she normally charges $100 an hour,
but she'll charge you 50 because he's so
small.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
That's when they do this thing.
They go near you with energy with the
Harris.
Have you ever had somebody new you will
want to blow your fucking brains out?
I had a lady do it to me and I don't
know what it does,
but they hover over you over your
Chakra,
whatever the fuck that is.
And the whole time I'm like,
I'm so angry that this person's dealing
because I want to try it,
because I had heard about it and I was
like,
well,
is it like a massage?
I didn't really know enough.
And it's not a massage,
it's nothing.
Oh,
she doing reiki treatment session,
please give me some volume so I can
understand how she's healing her vagina.
And she's hovering over a pussy.
She's like,
this area is hot,
warm.
You might have syphilis.
Go to a doctor.
What's up with your socks?
He's given up on life with those socks.
She's shutting it down.
Hold on.
I usually start at the bird.
I started at the third day.
I look at her.
She's super healthy.
Placing my hands on the client because I
don't want to press into her eyes.
You're not near her eyes.
Crazy bitch.
No,
it's her third eye.
Joe.
I'm sorry I'm.
Or approximately two to three minutes.
That's why it's infuriating it of this
demo.
I'm just going to take you through each
one explaining what
super healthy.
Looking at her.
She's got a chart on the wall,
so it's got to be legit.
The fucking short legitimize drawn like
a 19 sixties kung food diagram.
This is where the death touch is,
will push my stupid chart.
I had a lady cornered me at the comedy
store and tell me the cheese or a reiki
healer and she.
She made me put my hand down and I go,
what?
What are you going to do?
She's like,
I'm just to just so you can feel it,
and I go,
what am I feeling?
She was just put your hand out and just
empty your mind like,
okay,
done.
I put my hand down and she just hovers
their handover.
I go,
what are you doing?
And she's like,
you're not open.
This is not going to work if you're not
open.
I'm like,
oh,
well it's not going to work because you
just hovered in your hand over me.
She's like,
I'm a Reiki healer.
I might pitch.
You're crazy.
You're out of your fucking mind.
No,
she.
She's a shyster.
These are hucksters.
Yeah,
they believe.
I don't know if they believe some of
them,
but I don't want to generalize them into
one giant group,
but some of them must believe they're
doing something.
Well.
I think you have to believe it's working
too.
It's that CBF.
Yes,
exactly.
I mean,
look,
I've been hypnotized to stop smoking
cigarettes and it's been a lead on
stairs.
That's different,
but yeah,
completely.
Yeah,
but he knows this is legit.
and I think that's what I've been.
I've talked to.
I'm going to see if you agree with this.
I think that's what standup is.
I think when you're killing,
like say if I'm watching you,
if you're onstage and you're killing it,
I'm sitting in the back of the room.
I'm letting you think for me.
I'm like caught in your trance,
right?
You're like,
I'm not not thinking,
oh,
I don't know if I agree with her.
Maybe she's wrong.
Don't let her dress.
I'm sitting there and I'm allow.
If you're killing and I'm locked into
you and I'm really enjoying the show,
I'm allowing you to think for me and I'm
falling into this trance in sort of a
way and when and when you're making me
laugh,
then like I,
uh,
I have confidence in your thought
process that I'll let you take the reins
and I'll just sit back and have a good
time.
I
think there's something to that because
I was hypnotized for the first time last
year by a friend of mine.
His name is vinny shoreman and he does a
lot of work.
He's a hypnotist,
but he also does a lot of work with
fighters and he puts them in this state
and it's,
you're entirely conscious while this is
happening,
but he puts you in this very,
very relaxed state and you go over
things that you would like to work on or
go over.
Things that perhaps are bothering you.
Go over things that are bothering you
about the past.
But what it is is about putting you in a
state of mind where you can just relax
and think and not be overwhelmed by
extraneous information or things outside
of your control that's real.
That's,
that's like as real as meditation is
real.
But this shit
where I'm going to hover over your
vagina and pretend I'm cooking.
Here I am.
The energy.
You're not open Joe.
You're just not open to it.
If my hand was a marshmallow right now
and for a bit because I'm roasting over
your pussy.
She recovered her everything.
When she got to the vagina,
she stayed there for a long time.
She was like,
this is.
This is the area of your travels.
This is where it all stems here.
Plus the heat coming out of your hands
are sweaty.
Smell them stupid.
It just.
But people always want to find like
there's something wrong with me.
I have anxiety.
I'm living in traffic.
I don't like my life.
Someone fix me.
I'm going to put needles in your head
and all over the place.
That's a bunch of dog shit too.
Have you done acupuncture?
Well aligns too.
And I hated it.
I was so angry the whole time.
It hurts.
It fucking hurts.
It hurt for me.
It did.
I met.
Maybe she was doing it wrong.
I was having migraines.
Oh,
like 10 years ago.
But it's because I was on this birth
control pill that was fucking with me.
Oh No,
no,
no.
It's because you didn't get the needles.
You know why it wasn't open enough to
the Reiki.
Maybe if you just Reiki the fist right
in there.
Now go ahead and make a fist.
Put it in your ass.
Feel the energy massager in her colon.
Yeah.
I only did it once and it was a guy who
was a chiropractor too.
So you had double bullshit going on.
He adjusted my neck and then he stuck
needles in my head and he was trying to
fix my shoulder and I'm like,
how'd that go?
Turned out.
It was just a little slight little
muscle poll that I needed to get over.
Now.
What do you think about psychics and
mediums?
Bullshit artists.
Yeah.
I think I go with.
I think it is entirely possible that we
sense things that we don't have an
understanding of.
Like sometimes you feel something weird.
Like I was thinking about a friend of
mine yesterday and I hadn't talked to
him in awhile and he emailed me out of
the blue.
Right.
I don't know if that's coincidence.
I don't know what that is,
but the odds of it happening.
You got to think of how many times do
you think about your friend and they
don't email you.
Right?
Right.
Like why is it then when you think about
them and they do?
Is it just going?
I don't know,
but I think there are times where you
sense things that you don't have a sense
for.
Like there's a feeling that you get.
Well you don't understand and I think we
sent things about each other and maybe
their social cues that we're picking up
on.
Maybe there's maybe people give off
pheromones when they're upset me and
maybe those trigger you because we were
sort of designed to avoid confrontation
and certain individuals,
but I think this idea that they can look
at you and like your family is from a
sense of farm.
Desert
farm is your farm farming your plants,
so implants know what it is.
Is a potted plant sit by those?
Yes.
And you are close to a woman.
Who would that be a mother?
And My mother was a woman.
Mother.
Yes.
I see your mother.
Um,
I'm trying to picture out her name.
Is there an a in her name?
Magdalen man.
Dude.
I went to see this lady.
She knew everything about my mom.
A friend of mine went to a chiropractor
and the chiropractor,
a psych exam,
shit and same shit.
Different toilet.
He went to the chiropractor.
He knew all about my grandmother.
I go,
yeah,
don't you know about your grandmother?
You Know
Grandmother,
right?
So your chiropractor telling you shit
you already know or you're psychic
rather still killing the chiropractor.
Reiki healer knows shit about things
that you already know.
So they're telling you things you
already know,
like they're not psychic manipulating
you,
they're putting questions out there,
getting answers,
they've given you leading questions,
you're answering them in a very naive
way and you're giving them the
information because they're fucking con
artist.
Tell us asshole to tell you what your
future is telling me to tell you what
the lottery number is.
How come they never picked the lottery?
These fucks.
Right?
And Houdini had this thing where it
didn't he work it out with his wife or
something.
There's like a code word so that when he
died he would go from beyond have the
word that they would know and it never
happened.
Maybe it didn't like her.
Fuck that bitch.
Like I'm assets faction known rebecca.
I go by Penn and teller.
I'm friends with Penn and love him.
He just tells me it's 100 percent
horseshit.
Yeah,
like 100 percent flat out.
You know they have that James Randy
challenge.
You know,
that guy is offered a million dollars to
anyone that can prove actual psychic
powers.
No one's taken them up on it and no
one's ever James.
Randy.
That's the James Randy challenge.
What's the Long Island medium?
I think she might be a bullshit artist.
I one time I think I got hosed.
I did a show,
a podcast,
and the lady was.
She was good because I think.
I think what it is is people can read
your unconscious.
It's one unconscious reading,
another unconscious mind.
I imagine.
I feel like your father was an organist.
Am I right?
Yes,
but that's the thing.
They're telling you things that you
already know.
That's what drives me.
Fucking what's already a belief or
whatever in you versus new information.
What do you think about astrologers?
It's fucking stupid shit.
Right?
Shannon,
can I tell you something?
Whenever I meet a girl and she's like,
what's your sign?
And I'm like,
Jim.
And I just like,
I knew it.
You're such a jam and I what's your
husband?
And I'm like,
don't please don't like,
I can't pretend like I can't.
I can't subscribe to.
How can you not believe you're such a
Scorpio?
It's silly when you can find traits in
people and all sorts of people that
match all sorts of different.
Like I could be a virgo.
Taurus.
Yeah.
Oh,
you're so stubborn.
You're got towards Pisces.
That when such a Leo,
how could you not believe you're such a
Leo?
Yeah,
because I could read any,
any horoscope,
and it would probably apply.
Well,
what I really wonder about.
those are bullshit.
The real horoscope thing,
when you talk to the people that are
super into it,
they.
They literally want to know what time of
the day you were born,
what part of the world you were born,
and then they're like,
well,
you're a Gemini with a cancer ride.
Park.
Cut.
Stop.
It makes my asshole pucker.
Like even hearing it,
it's like a million alarm bells are
like,
dum,
dum.
I can't.
I can only go.
Stan.
Hope you still get to the coast.
We have a funny bit about how ridiculous
it is.
It's just,
it's fun.
It's fun,
but it's,
it's silly.
We're searching.
People are always searching for meaning.
You know?
We're always searching for someone who
knows something that we don't hidden
knowledge.
The secrets to the universe because
there's so much uncertainty that leaves
open the possibility that someone has
like,
I've been gifted,
I have a gift,
and you're like,
yes,
great.
Tell me.
I went to a psychic once.
I went to an audition in New York and I
was just like,
what am I doing with my life?
Walking to the train station.
I'm going to go to a psychic.
So I went to the psychic and she's like,
you have a brother?
No,
I don't have a psychic brother.
I feel like maybe you have a brother you
don't know about.
No,
no.
My mom had me when she was 20.
I have a sister shut the fuck up and she
made up a bunch of stupid shit and she
was talking about,
you're not sure what you want to do with
your life.
I go,
no,
I know exactly what I want to do.
Yeah,
I think what?
This is terrible.
You don't know what you're doing.
I had a lady just tell me right before I
shot my specialist psychic.
She goes,
I go,
what do you see in my future?
And I knew that the special was coming
and she didn't even know that I did for
a living.
And she goes,
I see you as like an interior designer.
Just guessing you have a real flair for
style.
I got.
I certainly do not.
This is the last thing I'm good at.
And where two different
colored socks.
Bitch look at me.
I'm an animal.
Like I don't know what I'm doing.
Crazy lady.
Why did you go see her?
Because there's a podcast.
It was a friend's podcast,
which they have mediums on and I thought
it'll be,
it'll be silly.
It'll be fun.
And you know,
I,
I got,
I got suckered in that day.
I think I did.
I really did.
I know if I'm being honest because my
mother died two years ago so I was Kinda
like.
And,
and I,
now that I looking back,
she did totally lead me down.
Like your mother was kind of nutty
though.
My mother was mentally ill.
Yeah.
Like legit,
like she was a borderline personality
disorder and then had schizophrenia too.
So it was fucking whackadoodles.
Do you have to do like self audits?
You mean aggressive therapy for the last
decade or so?
Do you look into your own brand?
Go and my wacky 24 slash seven.
Yeah.
Well that 20 percent more,
uh,
but I,
because I was,
I grew up alone with my mom,
my parents split and then I was raised
by a crazy person and so I've had to
like relearn how to think and what's,
what's the right way to do stuff and
that,
like I said,
I've been in therapy for a decade so
I've had to learn,
you know,
like I just had to relearn and it's
totally.
You totally can,
you know,
that's the thing.
Like I and I just want to talk.
I don't talk about it to be like,
oh poor me,
I had this thing but just didn't let
people know.
If you did grow up kind of Wacky,
you can fucking fix your brain.
You can reorient,
you can,
you can change how you think.
He doesn't have to stay sick,
you know?
Um,
how often do you go to therapy?
Every week,
dude.
And if I don't like I feel it.
Like I started,
I got to have a whole regimen.
It's the exercise,
it's the therapy.
It's eating,
right?
It's sleeping,
it's got to do it all.
Otherwise,
I mean,
I,
I get out of whack.
And what do you get out of the therapy?
Uh,
so I,
I believe in psychotherapy,
like getting back Friday and I like to
go back to the initial wound to the root
cause.
I like to go back,
look,
because what happens is you get wounded
way back when,
right at the childhood trauma,
the thing,
and then you grow up and it gets
triggered by whatever stuff happens as
an adult.
Except now you're all fired up and
you're all angry and you're so
overreacted and you don't know why.
Well,
it's probably not because of what
happened today.
It's what happened back here.
So if you resolve the ship back here,
then what happens today becomes a lot
clearer and it works for me.
So it makes sense,
right?
And don't think about what's going on
right now.
Think about why you feel weird about
what's going on right now.
What is it really?
Did my husband really just look at me
funny and that's why I'm so furious
about this little thing or is this
something that's Mommy Daddy way back
here?
Yeah,
because I think a lot of us live from
the past.
You live from the past wound.
You make all your decisions based on on
that programming,
so if you're fucking wires are crossed,
you're going to make bad decisions over
and over and over again.
I would imagine that anytime spent
thinking about your behavior,
thinking about the way you think,
just examining your own mind is as long
as you're really doing it justice.
So really being like so many people
don't
ever think about the way they think.
No,
they're just caught up in the whirlwind
of life,
the momentum of their own existence and
the next thing you know,
they're like miserable and 50 and like,
what am I doing?
Where am I?
Right?
Or it's the divorce and remarriage to
someone who's going to be better.
It's going to fix it.
He's going to fix it and he's my.
He's my soul mate.
I'm going to get.
I'm going to have an affair.
I'm going to do that.
I'm going to ask out here.
How's that gonna work for you?
I'm going to start doing drugs,
alcohol overheating,
whatever.
Gambling,
compulsive.
That'll.
That'll clear up this stuff,
right?
The gambling,
one of the weirdest one to me.
So many people that are compulsive
gamblers and I see the itch and them to
get that itch.
I'm so scared to gambling.
You go to Vegas.
I don't,
I don't like it.
I know it's not from your work there.
I have.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I worked there a lot.
You know,
I worked there like three or four times
a year,
you know,
for the UFC and uh,
I now spend zero time and casinos,
but I used to spend time because he
knows because I would stay in a casino
and then I would work in a casino,
but now I just stay outside of the
casino because it's just,
I don't enjoy being around that energy.
I agree.
There's this frantic gambler energy.
We see these people.
You walk by the card tables and they're
just looking and they're like,
whoa.
You're like watching people in an opium
den.
Yes.
Yeah,
it's depravity.
It's low energy,
low frequency.
There's the lightest synthetic,
the synthetic,
the time stops,
the I don't like that.
And you know,
it's what I figured out too is that
everyone's got the shit,
the addictions,
the gambling,
the compulsive behaviors because we're
afraid to feel the feeling.
You're just afraid of the feeling,
the that.
But I think it's also there is a reward
to winning and you're chasing this
reward constantly.
I don't necessarily know if it's a being
afraid of the feeling as much as being
addicted to the reward.
You know?
That's the two.
Like I was reading this article that the
guy who created likes on facebook was
saying that,
you know,
not only does he not use facebook,
now that he's got like a thing set up on
his computer where he can't go to reddit
and his phone is set up or you can't
download apps.
Like he doesn't like.
He's like that whole like thing where
you go to check to see how many likes
you got on a facebook post.
You may or something like that.
Like that.
Reward system is entirely,
it's addictive and it triggers this,
this thing in people and that it can
hijack your mind.
I mean that was like literally like the
title of the article is that like,
uh,
this technology can hijack your mind
without question at the reward system.
Right?
Like little rats.
Ding,
Ding.
I got the cheese.
The cheese.
There's mosquitoes.
People in front of the slots.
Yeah.
It feels good.
Just droned out.
But then when you're in the reward
system,
you're not thinking about the stuff
that's bothering you and everything's
great.
Love me,
Daddy.
Good,
good,
good.
I did think about that.
Gambling is a weird one,
man.
Yeah.
I don't understand it because you're
really self sabotaging.
Who?
Gambles of a storm.
I've heard this.
Yes.
Mania.
Hundreds of thousands of dollars a night
mania that I did not know.
Savage,
savage,
cannibal or what's the motive?
There was a big fan.
I loved it.
I loved him by the way.
As a child.
I think so,
so funny.
I love being friends with them.
I love them.
I'm friends with dice is the coolest
person on the phone.
Joseph,
Talk to me,
I love him,
but it's um,
he loves the thrill of gambling,
so I don't know,
but what is the thrill?
The way I avoid gambling altogether?
I'm,
I'm far too frugal,
but is it the,
is it the thing of like I can lose
everything?
There's a little of that.
There's a,
there's a rush of winning too.
It's not just the,
the,
the notion that you could lose
everything.
It's the rush of winning.
Wow.
Dana White's a giant gambler.
He's,
he's gambled.
He's lost as much as a million dollars
per night.
Is this as the circle as a surf board or
a president of the UFC?
Oh,
sorry.
Is he a band?
Uca.
Dana white boy band member.
I'm thinking of.
It's Shaun white boy.
You know what I've been getting into
lately?
Um,
breakdancers,
I fucking love breakdancing.
I love that whole.
I love that era.
There's a instagram page called stance
elements.
Okay.
Holy Shit.
These guys are on another level.
Yeah,
there's this,
a young Korean kid.
The shit that he does like defies
physics.
I think that column like pocket Kim or
something like that is his name.
He's on that stance.
Elements page.
Dude,
there's this school you can go to and
learn.
I don't want to try mine.
I'm having a hard enough time with
English.
That's the guy.
Yeah.
What is the name?
Bobby pocket.
Pocket pocket.
Okay.
Go to his watch this guy like this guy.
But no,
you can't believe the shit he can do.
Look at this.
Look at this dude.
Seriously,
what in the fuck this come on.
I mean,
what in the fuck?
This guy is on such another level than
anything I've ever seen before.
He's taken this to some completely new
place.
So Rad dude.
He was on.
Was looking at Tim Ferriss,
his instagram page blank.
Tim Ferriss.
Yeah.
And this was on it.
This guy was on it and I was like,
what in the fuck?
And then I started following stance
elements on instagram.
Once I started following on Instagram,
I realized like,
Oh my God,
I had no idea this was even happening.
Like there's,
it's girls too.
There's a bunch of girls.
Scroll down and see some of the girls
like you see,
like La,
there was a girl with long hair with a
hat on to keep scrolling down.
Just keep scrolling down.
There was girl on the dance floor type
situation with long hair and a hat.
Like,
keep going.
You'll find her.
Keep going.
No,
no,
no.
That might be one of them.
That's probably.
Yeah,
that's one of them.
Watch this girl shit.
There's a bunch of them,
but these girls can do crazy shit too,
like are unbelievable athletes.
So give me some music there Jamie.
But it's like.
It's a crazy like gymnastics,
rhythmic gymnastics art form thing like.
So they do the dance thing where they're
standing up and then they get down on
the ground.
It's so hard to imagine doing this shit
now.
No,
but what's really interesting is a lot
of these people that get into Jujitsu
are particularly talented at Jujitsu
because they have some amazing control
over their body.
One of our best students from 10th
Planet Jujitsu's,
the Geo Martinez
and Richie Martinez,
his two brothers and they're both
breakdancers.
They started out break dancing and now
they're fucking savage Jujitsu fighters
and one of the reasons why is because
they have this incredible control of
their body and that pant,
but I'm,
I'm fasting.
I go to that every day.
I'm like,
what's the new freak shit?
You find your instagram jams,
right?
Oh,
you have a lot of jams on instagram.
What's your other jam?
Let's go.
Oh boy.
I don't know.
I follow a lot of nature pages.
Oh,
nature.
Yeah.
Nature is metal is one of my favorite.
Cool.
Have you been in nature as metal?
Horrific.
Fucking animals killing each other.
You do like that because you always do
post shit.
Like,
look at this fucking beast and it's some
crazy animal.
Yeah.
I got to tell everybody,
look at that one.
These walls fighting over a deer that
they've killed.
That's bananas.
The covenant blood.
Um,
there's one that's going on right now.
It's not visual,
but it's a story on my friend Remy
Warren on his instagram page.
They were on an island in Alaska and
they got attacked by a giant grizzly
bear,
a giant Kodiak Brown bears.
A thousand pound bear knocked him over,
ran through the camp.
One guy was literally riding on the
bears back as it ran down the hill,
the little,
the bear literally attacked and there
was so many people and everybody
scattered in certain directions and
nobody got killed,
but they easily could have gotten killed
and it's on his instagram page.
There's that video,
but there's also an instagram story.
If you using the APP and you click on
this little icon,
it's like one of those where you see
like 100 dots in a row and he broke it.
I don't know how he did it.
He broke a long video down into 15
second chunks.
You record the whole video and that will
take.
You got to take time to put it up on the
story,
but.
But how do you do?
How do you do one where they seamlessly
go into the other where there's no
breaks?
Just use the next 15 second part.
Oh God.
It's a little bit of a pain.
That Dick.
There might be a better way,
but maybe there's a better way.
I don't think that there is,
but the way he did is so seamless.
It seems like there is a better way.
Maybe they're better at it now.
Anyway.
I'm a thousand huge.
Kodiak Brown bear charge them because
they had killed an elk and they had the
elk in camp.
They had to meet and camp and this bear
just ran over the top of the hill,
full blast at them,
knocking people left and right,
and they said it was only because there
were so many of them that they survived
and nobody got hurt.
One guy hit the bear in the face with
ski poles with like trekking poles and
the bear scrambled.
Like he said,
literally there was giant gnashing teeth
inches from his face and everyone went
full bananas.
Everyone went full reptilian.
They didn't see a common.
They had bear spray and pistols,
but they couldn't get to them in time.
They're like,
you think you can handle this?
Like you think you're prepared though,
oh,
I would've done this next time.
We should do this.
He's like,
there,
no.
Next time there's no you,
you,
you have no idea how you're gonna react
when a thousand pound bear runs at you.
Hell No.
I had a,
we had a rat in our house and I was like
terrified of killing it and seeing it
dead in the.
But I was excited to put down those
traps,
you know,
like the snap traps.
I was like,
I'm gonna fucking kill this thing.
Yeah.
I wanted to get like a,
a night vision camera just to make sure,
you know,
red band that he captured it on film.
Like the rat getting great in the tree.
It's horrific.
The thing is screaming.
The trap gets like,
I know.
I know when that motherfucker shitting
all over your house and shitting in your
kitchen,
that's all I want is to see in the hills
when you're in the hills,
you get rats.
No way around it.
No,
no.
They know.
It's so silly.
Is that that rat thing.
I mean we eventually caught it because I
poisoned the fuck out of our yard.
I was like,
no,
I loved it.
It was,
it felt good to kill it,
but I'm fucking showed up dead.
One day my kid was playing right next to
it.
I was like,
oh my God,
it's here.
And it was all stiff and I got to like
throw it away.
And it was good.
Um,
but it really made me realize maybe this
is like whatever tangent,
but I think I'm becoming more of an
atheist to cause you start to realize
that it really just is like humans
versus the elements.
Like it's just us trying to build a
fucking house,
trying to keep the road.
And so trying to keep your shit safe.
Bears from eating,
you,
trying to keep your young safe,
trying to get them raised.
It's,
it's,
we're just animals,
but we've got like cars and I phones and
Shit,
you know?
Yeah.
Well there's definitely a lot of that.
Oh shoot.
Oh,
I like vision.
I have this trap to trap one word
screams,
but oh yeah.
Is it a,
is it down?
I was trying to find it out and I don't
remember exactly where he had it.
He's got it up somewhere on instagram.
They caught them.
Good for him.
This is a good trap.
We have this one too.
It's an electric one,
I believe,
but he was hearing them in his walls and
shit.
God Damn it too.
Have you ever seen rats on Netflix?
Uh,
wwe.
No.
Dude,
the movie.
Stop what you're doing because I'm about
to ruin this documentary.
Rats on Netflix now,
bro.
It's fucking amazing.
It's so scary.
They're nasty as fuck.
Huh?
There's so and he realized how many
there are.
There's so many.
Oh my asshole just tangled and I knew it
overrun.
They say the weight in humans and the
weight and rats might be the same.
Really.
The weight,
the weight and the weight of rats,
like there might be as many pounds of
rat as there are pounds of p.
that's one theory.
They don't know like it's just guesswork
how many rats there are,
but they're convinced there's as many
rats as there are people.
There's 7 million people in New York.
There's 7 million rats,
but they say it might be as high as the
body mass,
like the bio mass of rats in the biomass
of people.
See,
that's why I knew when I fucking found
more.
Ended up,
man,
I don't know.
When you find one,
there's a bunch.
These unfortunate rats,
we're not part of the study were found
hung by the lower east side resident
last summer.
They hung rats.
Why they hang on.
Those are horrendous.
Why?
They hang them just to let all the other
rats.
Now listen.
You can't fucking neighborhood.
Let this be a warning.
You can't see those Cuban rats.
Cuba.
My husband went there once and they're.
They're called Nutria.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They have those in the south.
They hunt them.
They apparently they taste good.
Yes.
People Cook them.
Apparently.
It's like God.
Did Anthony Bordain have it on a show?
There was no,
it was on.
Another show was on someone's show.
Someone had a show about a like edible
wild animals that people take for
granted.
I forget what it was called,
but he cooked nutria and it was
delicious.
He made like this casserole or something
in Uganda.
In Uganda.
No.
Yeah,
it was in the south because I think.
And you've got to attend.
They fed him a rat and he was like,
it's delicious.
And you just knew that he was painting.
It was a yellow curry sauce.
I had squirrel.
I hear it's greasy.
Uh,
the way I had.
It wasn't greasy,
but it was good.
It tasted good.
It didn't taste bad is bad,
but it's not good.
I mean,
you've got to think it's a,
it's eating acorns.
It's like,
yeah,
it's probably just like rabbits,
like,
have you ever eat squirrels?
Probably saying I've had a rattle snake.
Jambalaya.
Really?
That's okay.
I've had,
I'll do.
I like alligator.
I was supposed to go hunt alligator with
a buddy of mine.
Those are cool.
Hunt for alligator fucking dinosaurs.
Do.
You're basically shooting a purse.
When I was on road rules back in the
nineties,
we had went to a crocodile farm and run
road rules.
90 MTV roles.
Step child of the real world.
Dude,
I was in a winnebago.
We went to Australia.
Uh,
the red headed stepchild was at the same
producers or something.
Same Company.
Bunin Murray and the real world was like
the flagship awesome show.
And then like a fraction,
you know,
watched the road rule.
Do you know Matt Kuehn?
It's one of the guys who was the,
you know Matt,
he's the guy who was a producer of a
fear factor.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
That's a friend of mine.
I vacation with them.
Oh,
well tell him I said I do love that
unit.
He's a great guy.
There's a lot of good people.
Good people come in here.
But anyway,
we worked at the crocodile farm and this
is back in the day.
There I am.
Look at you and not wearing jeans by the
way,
Dude.
You're a baby.
I know.
You're like a baby.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Let's zoom in on her low rez guys.
Wow.
And a better version of how old were you
then?
Like 20 or 20 crazy haircuts at 90
terabytes.
Isn't it funny that like how people get
on those shows and they like,
hey,
maybe something will happen out of this
and how few people things happen for me.
I didn't never know who.
Like Michael Michael.
Yo.
Do you know Michael?
Yes,
I do.
He goes show I'm the first ever episode
of fear factor really,
but he's really good.
He's really talented.
He's a great guy too,
sweetheart.
But he was like one of the rare guys
that made it through fear factor and how
many,
how many people do you think came on?
Fear factor being like,
someone's going to see me and I want to
be discovered and probably a few,
but you know,
it's not.
That wasn't the show like on American
idol now.
Even American idol,
like think about all the people that
were on American idol that like what is
the percentage of people that are on
America's got talent that actually have
a career afterwards.
It's,
well,
you know who,
who actually did was Melissa via Senor.
She was on a jet age as a kid,
say who's missile where she's now on
Saturday night live.
She's an amazing impressionist.
I mean this girl was on instagram every
day doing like Gwen Steffani,
Jaylee,
hold.
What's his name?
Osmot whole fucks.
Not from the sixth,
seventh.
Jelly suck my nuts.
She would do these obscure things and
they were spot on and she came on.
Your Mom's house and pretended to be
Gloria,
Stefan and was fantastic.
We played the call for Gloria,
Stefan,
and she was like,
oh my God,
this girl is amazing.
Like wow.
So she's on there.
So I would say that's for sure.
I know Melissa via senioritis.
Amazing fate or guy.
He has a fucking theater in Vegas,
but wasn't he always thought he was
successful prior to being on?
I don't know.
I mean he won.
America's got talent.
That's like his credit was winner of
America's got talent and they have a
theater named after him in Vegas.
It's bananas.
It's Terry fator theater season to
season two.
What are they up to?
Like season 90 now?
Who?
Wait,
hold on.
Who's that season?
10 Guy.
He's trying to be Terry fator this
motherfucker.
What's he doing?
This mother fucker?
British comedian.
Yeah.
I mean,
look,
he's got puppets.
Like there's not a whole lot of guys
with puppets in America.
Like,
stop and think about that.
What are the numbers of people that have
like a puppet act that are comics today
while we get the Big One?
Uh,
what's his nuts?
Oh,
come on.
The Guy,
he had the same manager.
Yeah.
That Guy Jeff,
a denim denim jumped out a huge,
huge.
He's giant.
He sells out arenas,
arenas and in like crazy markets that
you wouldn't want to.
She want it.
Good for you.
She's 12.
That's ridiculous.
Like if I can get her off the stage,
he doesn't know what she's doing.
Fuck,
that's little.
Simon.
Council.
Yeah.
Holly,
and then that's the spice.
What's her name?
Scary spice.
The comedian that did very well.
He made it to the finals.
His first thing he did in la I think was
on killed.
Tony.
He was on killed Tony a few times.
His name is preacher Lawson and he made
it all the way to the final design.
It's got high energy comedian.
Yeah.
Good.
That wow.
Got a lot of energy.
Yeah.
Jack the Kid.
He's taking a chance.
Wearing tight clothing too.
Distracting from us from a stage
persona.
Now.
That's an interesting.
We're talking about this with Brendan
Schaub show and he doesn't like to dress
to attractively,
like showing off his physique onstage
and women had the similar problems.
You.
I have huge tits and so one of my
problems with my special was like,
how do I fucking cover up these enormous
cans so people aren't like,
yeah,
please.
You know,
it's something about totes.
Well,
the first thing,
we were talking about this in the
beginning,
but when you're born and your mom goes,
here you go and you're like,
these are great.
Where can I get more of this?
Plus like tits or God's stereotypes with
the hope that like,
almost like,
like when you stare up at the sky every
now and then you see a shooting star.
If you stare at tests every now and then
it'll pop out like,
Whoa,
does that really happen?
Nip slips are real.
I've seen nip slips.
I've seen girls like they bend over to
like fix their shoe and the tip pops
out.
Oh my God.
Did you see that?
Like don't worry,
it's no big deal.
I looked away as soon as I saw it,
I'm being respectful.
So at what age does that,
like what age does that all calm down
and you become like a civilized human?
Oh,
sorry.
The question was this Narnia,
Lynn.
I think when you look at Harvey Harvey
Weinstein,
he's like 70 years old,
right?
How old is,
he said disgust and getting this rape
on.
He's too old to be that rapey.
Viagara cocaine 60.
Supposed to 65.
But I think he,
when he come this nasty,
nasty hot.
Yeah,
of course he farts when he comes.
Look at him.
Oh my God.
Question.
How does a guy,
um,
bounce back?
This is not balanceable.
No,
no.
So what do you do this,
especially in today's culture where
it's,
there's no hall pass anymore for this
Shit,
right?
He's just got to go into hiding or like
bill cosby do the complete deflection.
Like I don't know what these images are
talking about.
Like he's in total denial,
but he's also a blind.
That's true.
Cosby's almost completely blind.
And so that.
It's weird when you look at it.
I'm like,
Shit.
It's like,
it's almost like my body is failing on
his reality.
The evils,
making them blind.
I was a fan of his in a big way when I
was a little kid.
Of course,
I remember listening to a bill cosby
himself.
I mean his eyes were all fucked up.
Now guys like really aggressive
glaucoma.
Go with the one above.
It is the art,
the folded hands.
Like that picture right there.
That's the mugshot.
Got It.
It's just so weird to go from that
picture to the one in the upper right
where he's smiling like what happened?
Like this was,
this was the guy we thought we were
getting right now that we're getting
Jello pudding America looking at me
smiling.
Imagine if you were the girl who this
guy raped.
Oh my God.
And you had to watch him be like America
sweetheart.
And you're like,
no,
you're a monster.
You're,
you're,
you're taking people's humanity.
It's so crazy.
Like the Hugh hefner thing,
he's just a freak.
You know?
They know what they're signing up for.
He's not dragging anybody.
That's true.
And,
and everyone's kind of aware.
Yeah,
it's creepy.
It's not going to be great,
but there is an exchange here.
You get free rent.
The Pajama thing.
Even Harvey's not drugging anybody.
I don't know that we don't know yet.
I don't know.
I'm just talking shit,
but I'm,
I'm for the stories that I've,
I'm here and he's just like,
was just trying,
like again throwing.
He's,
he's missing a lot of pitches like over
the years.
Right.
So if 25 women have come forward,
how many did he just fucking knock it
out of the park?
Inside the mind of Bill Cosby.
Why?
What do you wish we could really get in
there?
It's just like pills,
rape,
rerecord that humming and people are
asleep.
How is that your favorite too?
Like I need you to be totally dead.
I don't know.
Um,
I've heard theories.
One of the theories that I heard that
was kind of interesting is that when you
are that much of a celebrity in a time
where there's no repercussions like pre
Internet,
right?
Yeah.
That your,
um,
your thoughts of who you are in
comparison to who other people are,
is that you really literally feel like
you're royalty.
You are,
you're better than other people.
Mean I worked at a casino wants and they
told me that this was before bill cause
we got arrested.
This was when the allegations were just
before they were even emerging.
This was before anything happened.
They were talking about how weird he was
and that he made the employees all sit
down and watch him eat curry.
He,
uh,
he had to have everybody in that was
working there,
door people,
box office.
They had to sit in the room with him and
watch him while he ate.
And then he had a security guard,
tuck him into bed,
like literally talk him into bed at
night when he went to sleep.
What's the curry though?
Wanted people to watch a meat and then
watch them take a shit.
Like,
I don't even think.
I mean you could,
you could be generous and say,
well maybe it was like his way of
getting over stage fright.
Like he gets over the feeling of people
watching him.
Does he all these people staring at them
and then going onstage.
Like it could be an effective strategy.
Like if you really think about it,
have you have a room full of people that
are just staring at you and you just
doing normal stuff and then you go on
stage.
It's like you've kind of relaxed.
Sure.
The.
Does that make any sense?
No,
no,
I meant does it does for somebody who
would.
Who would I just.
For me personally,
the power move of doing that is such an
asshole thing.
Like,
hey everybody,
stop what you're doing.
Watch me eat curry.
It's so absurd.
It's like,
do you really need that?
Is that
this?
So the woman who was working there was
telling me that's how she was thinking
about.
She's like,
he's so weird.
I was like,
how so?
And then she was just telling me all
these stories in the dressing room and
I'll be standing around.
That's a power move though.
20 people.
That's a power.
That's,
that's hey,
do do what I say.
Yeah.
Taught me in,
Tuck me,
talk to me in.
I keep it.
Climb in bed and you'd have to like,
like a little Burrito Burrito.
Read them and go to sleep.
Mood now who shot the light out?
Now?
Leave.
That's so dark.
Well I,
you know,
like a lot of these people have like a
whole team of handlers opened the door
for Mr Cosby,
you know,
like Mr Cosby sits down,
you might want to buckle them up on a
buffalo hump.
Mr Cosby,
Mr Cosby just sits there.
You buckle them up and he just drives
weird.
Yeah.
It's not even like,
I don't know.
I can't connect.
Some people.
I think I probably liked the idea of
royalty like being royal.
It sounds like a jail.
Sounds terrible.
I follow on instagram a kate,
you know the,
the new royal and Kate.
It's kate of Berkshire or whatever.
Fucking prince and Princess Kate Shaw
and it's such as Kate Middleton.
Yeah.
Kate Middleton.
And the fantasy.
And I think in addition to the like
thing,
right?
That,
that sort of whatever culture is the
culture of people putting forward their
best image all the time.
You're not really posting.
Yeah.
And could you imagine the absolute hell
of being that 24 slash seven?
I mean,
I,
I would have it so much,
but someone look forward to that.
Someone did someone go,
Oh,
I wish there was some girls dreaming of
being Kate Middleton.
Be Amazing.
I want to be kate.
Look at her.
She's very nice.
Yeah,
no,
she's fantastic.
She's doing a great job.
He's got a hog on them.
No.
What tall skinny guy might have a hard
high.
You know the Brits are not known for for
hogs.
I lived in England for a year.
I did not do anything.
I didn't touch on English hog,
but I had a gay friend that was touching
all of the hogs and he was like,
I'm not impressed.
Not impressed.
Yeah.
What it will be.
This comment score.
Great.
Grandfather John committed suicide at
age 30,
43.
His sister Julia remained a spinster her
whole life.
I believe she lived with brother
Ebeneezer.
The shipwright fuck.
Fuck kind of comment.
Is that this guy's leaving a bunch of
comments currently.
Yeah.
Was just weird.
Just a bunch of stuff talking to him.
Yeah.
We'll get this Iran deal.
What kind of obtrusive,
scandalous and disgraceful gnosis is
this?
I am not one of the grand and glorious
vetted ones privy to the global secrets
like,
oh,
this guy's a nut.
This guy is leaving some interesting
comments.
This is Kensington,
royal instagram page.
How many likes they have?
Their 119,000
conor mcgregor shits on you royals.
He shits on your numbers to two point 2
million spit at that.
You know what's a great instagram is a
passenger shaming that.
Oh,
it's fantastic.
It's a.
it's a flight attendant and she takes
photos of people putting their nasty
feet up on the seats and on the trays
and acting like fools and then she puts
it up and they talk some shit.
It's fantastic.
Yeah.
See people look at this.
Look at this.
Nasty people are gross.
Putting your feet up on the fucking
thing.
Oh yeah.
I just had someone do it last week to
me.
They put their foot in between the seat.
See how that dog is there?
What was
there?
You saw the foot where you're looking
down.
It was right there.
Did you say anything?
No,
I just took a patriot.
Put It on instagram.
It is nasty.
People are fucking gross and sometimes
their feet will touch you,
like if someone's hand touches you.
No big deal.
Yeah,
the foot.
You're fucking stinky feet.
My daughter,
the other day,
the same one that's making me wear this
bracelet.
A daughter made this bracelet for my
seven year old.
She's fucking hilarious.
She had a bandaid on her finger and she
kept it on all day and she goes,
dad,
smell my finger.
I'm like,
I lost my finger.
She was,
come on,
smell my finger.
I don't want to smell your finger.
She goes,
it smells like roses and I smell it.
Smelled like Joey Diaz his feet.
So now she's laughing.
She's like,
ah,
it's disgusting.
She thought it was so funny that she got
me to smell it that I gave in after I'll
go,
okay,
this is a tiny little seven year old.
Like it's just so funny to her.
It's so good.
It's funny when you see this about your
son,
as he gets older,
they have their own little way of
talking and thinking about things and
communicating with you and the little
calculated way of interfacing with the
world.
So weird.
I see it already.
I see some
manipulation.
Ted Talks.
He's starting to.
Yeah,
words,
words that done.
You can say certain things.
Yeah,
that's cute.
As a bug.
I love it.
It's so amazing.
I like it was strange or making people.
It's bananas and I always.
We look at him and I'm like,
tweet.
We made this dude like one weekend in
Virginia beach when you were at the
funny bone,
but we're reading at Ruth's Chris and
then this fucking guy.
When you see Tommy now with this crazy
fitness routine.
I mean he,
he looks fantastic.
I mean I saw him the other night.
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
look how fucking great you look like
he's.
He lost all that weight from the weight
loss challenge and then just fucking ran
with it.
He is so much happier now and I,
I sing the praises of the fat shaming
campaign and I think that shaming is
such a wonderful tool to get people to
jumpstart whatever it is that they need
to,
but people don't want to hear that.
No,
but shame is a wonderful.
It's not,
it's not necessarily bad to feel shame
shaming is okay in small doses.
It's motivate you.
Yeah.
Some people need to be motivated and in
whatever way they can get,
but the thing is it makes people feel
bad and people don't want people to feel
bad.
Yeah.
Well feeling bad is what makes you
change.
But some people in the shame you,
they're shaming you because they're just
being mean.
Any positive consequences that come from
that are just in consequential.
They're just,
they're just lucky.
But in this case,
I think it was a constructive shame and
other.
We're both wanting to lose weight in
there.
Tom and burt were both shitting on each
other equally back and forth.
Yes.
So crazy.
But what was interesting is like fans
got really into it and we're really mean
about it.
Yes.
And uh,
and really funny about it,
we got many submissions on your mom's
house,
international submissions of like,
uh,
English teachers and their classrooms,
like teaching them how to say burtis fat
in English and then like speaking Indian
or something,
it was,
it was really cool.
So many videos I started doing like
local TV stations and talking to them
about how fat burgers just get online
and it just got so crazy,
you know,
and then people would go to burt's show
and yell out Tom's fat.
Yeah.
You know,
and like Tom's shows people yell out
wise.
So fat.
I definitely think the bird is fat
campaign took off a lot.
I would say that guts and heat and uh,
I think his podcast births is struggling
in comparison to Tom's doors.
I think you guys have a much more
powerful presence online.
Yeah.
And it's like he fucked with the wrong
dude.
He did.
He did fight with around it.
Now sober October.
We are how many?
Eleven days in?
Yeah,
today's the 11th.
Everybody knows I'm not smoking pot.
All right.
Why?
Because I got shamed into it because it
was being a fucking bitch is what you
can't smoke pot like I can.
It's just that wasn't part of the deal.
And I thought about it on September 31st
or whatever it was.
September.
What is it?
Thirty one.
Thirty,
30.
And I was like,
fuck this.
I'm like,
I don't need to smoke pot,
I'm going to take the whole month top
pot too.
So I've taken the whole month out pot
and one of the things that's interesting
is my dreams aren't.
Hence,
I had a dream last night and maybe it
was [inaudible].
I'm paying attention all this Harvey
Weinstein chip.
I had a dream last night that there was
some Russian woman who was married to
some Russian dictator.
Dude that was seducing me and I was
terrified seducing you are the girl.
The woman was,
she was like,
uh,
some really hot Russian woman,
but I was terrified of her because she
was the wife of some really powerful
man.
And she was like making me hang out with
her and like I didn't fuck her in my
dreams.
But uh,
like I was like,
you know,
basically like being submissive to her,
it was very strange and we were on a
boat somehow or another,
like it was super vivid.
We're looking at.
And I looked out the window and another
boat was really close to us,
but it didn't collide with us.
I'm like,
oh,
but it was like super vivid and I was
thinking like,
wow,
like,
and um,
this was last night.
Yeah.
And I was thinking I didn't have any
Alpha brain before I went to bed either.
It wasn't like one of those dreams,
but it was a,
it was really vivid,
like really.
And that's one of the things that I'd
heard when people stop smoking pot,
is it their dreams become very vivid and
you remember your dreams
now in my,
my therapist will do dream analysis on
me.
Uh,
and it's usually people who represent
either feelings you have or you don't
really dream you dream and symbolism.
Right?
So the Russian lady could be whoever,
it could be your mother,
your sister,
your
wife.
You're represented power to me,
like the feeling of being like,
you know,
like it's,
it's very unusual for a man to feel like
they're in a position where a woman has
power over them unless it's your boss.
Right?
So for me it was like this feeling of
this woman who I couldn't say no to and
I was scared of because she was like
the,
she was married to some dictator,
you know,
and she's like,
come into my room.
I went to go with me.
She was really beautiful.
I was like,
oh,
okay,
yeah,
sure,
I'll do whatever.
But I was like really?
Like,
nervous around her and said,
no,
not in the dream now unless I forgot
that part.
Yeah.
I mean it was really weird.
It was like,
because I was like,
I better do what she says,
like one of those things.
And I was thinking like a modern,
whether that's,
if that's what it feels like to be like,
like someone how to deal with someone
like Harvey Weinstein.
I was wondering if that's what planted
that seed in my head.
Like if I was a young starlet hoping to
make it in the business and he was the
guy that held,
you know,
possible my future in front of me.
Right.
Well also the dreams.
Uh,
anyway,
my shrink says that when you do your
dream analysis,
a lot of times it's feelings you can't
deal with in waking life.
So it's the feeling in the dream.
What do you our powerlessness would
think they would say about this dream?
I don't know because I don't know enough
about your personal life.
It would have to know more about your
dynamics,
like between your wife,
your,
whoever else is in your world because
it'll always represents other people you
won't,
you won't ever dream.
Like if you have problems with your
mommy and your daddy,
it's not really.
You never,
for instance,
whenever it's just so weird.
But whenever I dream about my father,
I actually dream about Howard Stern.
Like I associate the two.
Yeah.
So Howard starting shows up so they have
a similar sense of humor and I grew up
on stern and I see stern is like a
paternal,
you know,
he could be my dad like in a lot of ways
he's my comedy dad.
Like I grew up just worshiping.
Starting.
Yeah.
So whenever I start,
I know,
it's like,
oh,
I have it.
It's a data issue that would you be
weirded out if you did a show?
I would fucking love.
It's so much.
It's my dream.
That's one of my.
I don't get geeked out on celebrities.
I don't really care.
P would be the only one that I had been
nervous.
He was
the most important thing that I ever did
for sure.
To me.
In my mind he was like,
like I didn't give a fuck if I was on
the tonight show didn't mean anything to
me.
I was never a tonight show comic like my
in my mind,
like all those things were like for
people who want to do seven clean
minutes.
And I was a Kennison guy.
You know?
I liked Kennison.
I,
I liked,
I like dice,
you know,
I like Richard Pryor.
Like I didn't want to be that kind of
squeaky clean comics.
So to me Howard stern was like this
groundbreaker,
like he was the first guy to ever just
do an all talk show on regular radio.
Right.
I mean he used to do songs used to play
records,
but then it became just the stuff in
between the records was even better and
then it became all that and when I was a
kid,
I mean I've heard like there was some
funny shows in Boston with back in the
day when they had real djs and shit like
that,
but I'd always heard about stern,
you know,
and then once I first started listening
to them and it was like he was on in
Boston as well and I was thinking like
that.
That's the,
that's the holy grail.
Like that's when you get there.
Especially then back in the day when he
was on like regular radio and everybody
was listening.
I was like,
you know,
he'd get like 18 million people
listening to a show.
Crazy.
There's nothing I'd ever like that
before or since.
No.
And I used to,
I worked in my dad's shop.
My Dad had a forklift repair shop and
I'd have to fucking work there every
summer.
And I remember starting at like 12 years
old.
I started listening to stern.
He was on the radio here in La in the
mornings and I would be so bummed when
those four hours were over and then I
have to listen to whoever fucking
dickhead was on after like whatever fake
nonsense radio and then like.
But Bango Fiesta came out.
That was the shit and they had like the,
you know,
the KKK guy.
A self was so.
It was so radical.
It was so funny.
Remember private parts,
of course I've seen it a million times.
Yeah.
You know to me too.
He also represented this fight against
the suppressive free speech of the right
wing people that were empowered at the
time because the FCC went after him in a
huge way.
They were finding Istation,
hundreds of thousands of dollars for
doing like potty jokes or something like
that.
I am talking about penises.
Like they would attack them and like
literally find them hundreds of
thousands of dollars.
It was a direct assault on free speech
because it wasn't even words.
They were,
wasn't
even forbidden words was like topics.
They were deciding what people could and
couldn't say,
and he was for all of us who are comics,
he was at the front of the line of that
shit.
I mean,
he was,
he was the guy that was taking the hits
and in a lot of ways it boosted them,
you know,
because everybody was aware that he was
being attacked and people were outraged,
but it was,
it represented when Bush was in office,
when Bush was the president,
and we were all kind of freaked out by
that this was happening,
you know,
this,
this guy who was this really funny guy.
They were deciding who was a criminal
and they were finding his station,
hundreds of thousands of dollars for
what?
For,
for making people laugh,
like so crazy.
Yeah.
So for me it just represented so much.
It was just so.
It was so crazy.
It was just.
That was the most nervous I've ever been
in my life the night before I did it and
actually I did yoga the night before I
did it.
I did yoga in my hotel room to calm
myself down and it worked.
Yeah,
yeah.
Super,
super calm
to the beat like I would love.
I would probably happen.
Um,
do,
do.
What about,
what was I gonna say?
Oh,
I forgot.
I forgot now.
I don't know.
Got Mommy brain.
I got mommy.
Brain is a real thing for sure.
Is it totally changed?
I don't sleep through the night anymore.
I wake up all night shift things too.
Right?
Like what?
What's going on for anything?
Okay.
I sense everything man.
My spidey senses are always on as a
mother.
I imagine.
I don't know what's up.
Get a little human you made with your
own body.
It's fucking bananas.
I don't know why women act like it's not
the biggest deal in the world.
It is the craziest thing in the world.
Women Act like it's not the biggest
deal.
I feel like it's very normal for some
people.
Like I just feel like I feel like we
need to be like blown away by it
constantly and we're just not blown away
by it enough.
Well,
you know what,
you don't have a,
you know,
50 hours a week,
day job,
Dick head for a husband.
You know what I mean?
Maybe that's why for those fucking kids
to.
I guess I got to feed it.
I don't know.
I mean I think it was the experience is
different depending on what kind of
relationship you have with your partner,
you know?
Yeah,
definitely.
Sounds like you have a gay girl can say
partner like a guy said that to me about
his girlfriend once.
Well,
you know,
me and my partner,
we've been living together for a while.
I'm like,
what?
Your partner partner.
That's what.
That's a homosexual.
Yeah.
Tom and Helen,
his wife,
his partner.
That's only for gays.
Partner in crime.
You guys,
criminals.
Liquidity here.
Your business partner we're talking
about.
It was just such a weird way of
describing it.
My partner Monroe for too close for
comfort or put a strap on on you,
Bro.
We were watching as good as it gets last
night.
And Greg Kinnear,
those other things.
That movie.
Oh really?
I love it.
Angry.
Well part.
What made you angry as he,
because he's a racist,
I'm going to fix it with a pill,
but it was so fucking stupid.
Is it like she seemed like this really
sweet woman who had a kid and Jack
Nicholson was his old car.
That's as good
as it gets.
Like what kind of fucking messages after
Peter,
this is so stupid and the writing was so
dumb.
I was like,
Oh,
you're going to fix his racism with a
pill or get the fuck out of here.
That is so stupid.
No,
I don't hate spicks like fuck off
fucking stupid movie.
I hated that movie.
Like this poor lady.
She seemed so nice.
Like maybe find a nice guy.
I swear to you.
I never thought of it that way.
She just settles for this old Shitty,
racist repo who needs to take drugs to
make him somewhat normal.
He takes drugs to make them not a
racist.
It's the stupidest idea ever.
Any kind of manipulates her by sending
the doctor over to care for her child.
She's.
She's a neat.
She has no money.
As good as it gets.
This is not as good as it gets.
Hang in there,
sweetie.
You can get better.
You could do a lot better.
A pretender.
Jack Nicholson.
She couldn't swipe right.
She couldn't ask why?
No,
there was no swiping magnetic.
Just got to find some other Nice Dad and
your.
Your kid gets along with their kid and
you have another fucking brady bunch of
for you.
That's the story of a man named Brandon.
What's her name?
Alice just died,
right?
Yeah.
Who's alive still?
Dad died of AIDS.
That was bananas.
Right in front of the dad was actually
taken in the no idea I was wanting to
meet Greg Kinnear,
his character.
His parents disowned him because he's
gay and and last night Tom was like,
can you believe this shit?
This is like what?
Twenty years ago this was.
That was considered a thing that you
would disown your child.
Yeah.
Now it still is a thing.
Yes,
it is.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
South Dakota.
They fucking kill you.
Fuck you.
Rogan were normal.
No Internet.
I'm kidding.
Folks.
I run out of things to say they have a
free ball.
They bow hunt the quiz.
The quiz.
Is that.
What'd you guys do?
Hunt the gaze.
No,
no.
The gays aren't edible.
The Queen.
Can you imagine?
I was reading this thing about cannibals
the.
I know it's a weird thing to say.
I guess you had to dance around you.
You couldn't be like my boyfriend.
My girlfriend knows his wife.
He was calling.
It was connor is partner.
People are so fucked up.
Well,
it's almost think that a guy like that
is like so programmed by like liberal
sensibilities that he's like,
he wants to put her on equal ground.
It's not my wife.
I don't own her.
She's my partner.
We're in this together.
Totally drinking the Koolaid.
Bitch made men.
There's so many just bitch made men out
there that just wearing slippery shoes,
walking around with tight pants on and
take a punch.
Just just barely getting through life
early men.
They're barely men.
I,
you know,
it's so funny because Tommy yesterday he
goes,
you know Christina,
you're,
you're like in 19 thirties man,
so fucking well you know,
because I'm a little traditional.
I actually am very traditional about
this kind of stuff.
Did look the truth of it is the fucking
guy at wearing the string bracelets and
the thumb ring and the pony tail and
your shock alignment in the Reiki.
That's just a fucking thing for him to
get laid at the end of the day.
He's just trying to convince you to fuck
him.
Well,
he's just trying to play the spiritual
angle.
That's right.
That's his game.
This is what I was saying on stage last
night.
You know I did Jeremiah walk and show.
You ever do that show too?
I hear it.
So fun.
Stand up on the spot.
Make up things.
People yell things out at you,
but one of the things I was saying,
we were talking about male feminists.
Somehow the subject came up and I was
saying if you could give any one of
those guys a pill that would turn them
into that thor dude,
that Chris Hemsworth,
dude,
they would all take it.
Are The bond powerful?
And then didn't.
They would just be themselves.
They wouldn't have to.
Like I was talking about this tweet that
I read that literally made me want to
punch my fist through the fucking
laptop.
This guy said,
I'm not calling myself a feminist until
women tell me I'm doing feminism
correctly.
It's just like literally cutting off his
dick and offering it on a platter.
I don't need this.
I'm not about that.
I'm spiritual.
Well,
and here's the truth.
I mean,
at least for me,
I appreciate when a man is down for the
cause.
Like I,
I get that,
but it's not sexually.
It's not attractive to data.
A guy that's like a girl.
For me personally,
I like,
I like men.
It totally 100 percent sexist.
Yeah.
Probably.
I don't know.
When I answered girl be sexist.
I don't even know.
I feel like it's okay for a girl to want
a traditional gender roles.
It's very suppressive if a guy wants
them.
That's the thought process.
Oh,
I see you're saying?
Yeah,
because we have the option to be like
the stay at home mom or the career lady.
But if you want like a guide to be a
man,
that's okay.
But if I like a woman to just shut the
fuck up,
let's be banger.
People like what?
Right.
You're considered?
Yeah.
Say I like a guy who just grabs you by
my here and fucked my mouth.
You're like,
whoa.
well,
she's so empowered.
Wow.
There's a lady that she's a slut.
Shamed.
Yeah.
She can be herself.
I don't know.
You know what?
I think I just,
all of our issues stem the real issue.
All of our issues stem from actual
sexism,
actual discrimination.
If,
if we didn't have that,
if we just had people judge by on the
merits of their behavior and their
character and what they're capable of
and we would just look like this.
One of the things about the standup
comedy world,
like maybe audience members like you,
I mean you would be able to tell much
more than I would that they,
you know,
I definitely think that some guys see a
girl go up and they go,
oh,
we'll shoot for me.
Right.
That was the whole environment I came up
in.
For sure arms folded.
Fuck is this girl,
I refine it.
Great.
How long is she up for?
Fifteen minutes.
We took a post 100 percent go to the
bar,
but in the world of comics it's very
egalitarian if you kill you or you're a
comic,
right?
Like nobody.
None of that.
Nobody in the comedy world looks at Ali
Wong as a girl.
She's amazing.
She's just a comic.
She's,
she happens to be a girl,
but she's,
she's just a killer.
Right?
That's how everybody looks at her.
Like there's like,
there's like a thing,
there's like a level of the video game
that you get to where you slot into,
oh,
this is a peer,
like she's a killer.
You know?
And that's,
that's an interesting thing about the
world of comedy.
Like when you're a killer,
people think of you as a killer.
It doesn't matter if you have a vagina
or a penis,
if you're gay or you're straight.
If you're murdering it,
you're,
you're in that group.
Right?
It's the great leveler.
It.
Yeah,
it's a very,
it's very true.
Yeah,
because nobody can hold your hand for
you once you get up there.
No,
no,
and it's,
it's a,
it's a very ballsy thing to do and
either you fail and you fail or you
succeed and you succeed.
Heart,
there's no,
there's no middle ground,
but I definitely think women have a way
harder go at it because I think that
sexual topics that you either are the
slut,
like you were saying before or they're
weird,
right?
Because if you're just a regular woman
and you're talking to these strangers
about like how you like your asshole
licked and you're really embarrassed
about it.
People are like,
what the fuck?
You know,
and girls will get mad at you.
If you're attractive.
Girls get mad at you because you're
their husbands laughing.
Like that's funny.
She's reps,
she's disgusting.
And then politics are almost off level
for you.
I mean,
people get mad at you,
they will get mad at you if you like.
You're a trump supporter and you're a
woman and you're on stage and there's a
bunch of people in the audience.
There are liberals.
They'll get mad.
Forget you're a liberal onstage and this
trump supporters in the audience and you
start shitting on trump.
They'll get mad at you.
Stick to the job with depaul jokes,
the jokes.
Well,
what I've noticed is that at least
here's my thing,
I have hope for this.
The millennials,
I think they're changing how comedy is
consumed.
The podcasting world.
It's millennials,
the early adapters,
and they grew up watching Sarah
Silverman,
Lisa Lampanelli,
all these motherfucking bad bitches.
So now in the millennial comes to a
shell.
That 20 year old boy doesn't have the
same bias that the men who I started in
front of a hat.
You know what I mean?
It's a given that if a woman is a comic,
now it's cooler.
It's way different.
Well,
don't you think there's,
I like to think I'm not a millennial,
but I'd like to think there's less
sexism.
Yeah,
no less accepted.
Yeah.
I mean,
when I started featuring,
I literally called the club in the
Midwest and I was on Chelsea lately.
I go,
okay,
can I,
uh,
can I dear room kind of headline or even
just feature no feature.
Well,
you know,
Christina have already booked to women
this.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Whole year,
the whole year guys,
that's 52 weeks.
50 of them.
Yeah.
And uh,
and I was like,
wow,
I'll never under your fucking club
again.
But you know,
I heard shit like that the whole time
coming in book two women.
Imagine if that was a guy.
Oh my gosh guys,
was that hard to get into comedy already
booked two dudes was only,
have so many swinging dicks.
No,
but you know,
but that feminism shit and I,
I try not to look at the,
the problems of the world.
I try to fucking transcendent like I
can't even spell.
I used to be so much angrier at feminism
and all this shit when I was in my
thirties and then I now I'm just like,
you know what?
I don't give a shit.
I don't care what society wants me to be
or what the fucking rules are.
I don't care.
Fuck you at life is too short for me to
even worry about what this person thinks
or the society is thinking.
Well,
I think that like what you're seeing,
like on college campuses where people
are super radical,
left wing progressive as in I think
you're seeing that with young people as
well.
I think people are just trying to work
out the world,
you know,
and sometimes they work out the world by
assuming some sort of a behavior pattern
in that behavior pattern.
Could be right wing or it could be left
wing.
I mean it can be feminist,
it could be,
you know,
whatever.
That could be gender queer.
They'll try that out for awhile.
I'm going to shave half my head and wear
a nose ring and say fuck cis gendered
men and people get weird and they just
assume these patterns and try them out
for awhile.
Almost like dressing punk rock,
you know,
start wearing doc martins.
Ruin your jeans up.
That was really good at that.
Did you do that?
My Lane.
I was punk as fuck.
Goth and punk for any weird piercings in
the face.
The nose or the lips.
No,
I know.
I was too sensible because I knew that
I'd have a hole in my face.
Woo.
You're always so controlled.
Yeah.
I only have one shitty tattoo.
I got a tramp stamp in the nineties on
road rules.
Woo.
Yeah.
Do you think that that control things
because your mom was nuts?
Yeah.
My world was out of control,
so I was like,
I have to be responsible.
I was the one that was responsible from
the time I was a little little kid.
I grew up fast.
Right.
That makes sense.
Parentified child,
as I said,
isn't that
so?
You find that a lot.
It's interesting.
It's like I have this dilemma.
I've talked about this with Bryan County
as a lot of my friends that are dads.
It's like all my interesting friends
came from fucked up childhoods,
but I don't want that for my kids knew.
Right.
So what is that like?
All my favorite people came from
childhoods game.
Recognize game son.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah,
but it's because your,
your wires or whatever.
Crossed a certain way.
Same way similarly,
but you don't want to fuck up your can.
I have the same dilemma.
Believe me,
I don't want my son.
Then again,
I'd be super thrilled with my son grew
up and was like,
I'd love,
I'm going to be an accountant,
I'm just going to be normal.
I don't want him to be in show business.
Like,
this is the,
this is craziness.
This business is not for normal people.
Especially Avenue that you've
carved standup.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We've carved horrible.
It's crazy.
It's bananas and I,
I was just,
I mean when I look back on who we
started with like 14 years ago and the
attrition rate,
I mean there's no real,
it's just bananas that we can even make
a living at this.
Like there's no reason I should be what
I'm saying.
It's crazy.
Well,
it's one thing that,
you know,
you start off and you suck and you keep
working at it and suck less and then you
start getting laughs and he started
doing better when they start working and
you keep building and keep moving as
long as you keep moving and sometimes
you'll have some setbacks.
Like probably you when you were doing
Chelsea lately and me when I was doing
news radio and you know,
and you just,
if you can get back on the horse,
get back moving.
Yeah,
you can pick it up and next thing you
know you've got a motherfucking Netflix.
It's available right now and we'll wrap
it up with this mother and fear
available for screaming,
screaming,
and streaming both right now.
God dammit,
Christina Pezeshki,
ladies and gentlemen,
and make sure you watch and listen to
your mom's house.
Fantastic podcasts.
And uh,
let's do this more often.
Thank you so much for having me.
Thank you.
I enjoyed it too.
All right folks.
We'll see you soon.
Bye.